Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the rest is history.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is presented by Adobe Express, the quick and easy create-anything app. What does that mean? Well, say you need to make a presentation or a video or a social media post or a flyer to some, certainly to me, that sounds intimidating. But Tom, with Adobe Express's intuitive features like templates, generative AI and real-time collaboration, it has never been easier. Adobe Express. Try it for free. Search Adobe Express in the App Store.
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）。想要获取每周的独家播客节目、无广告收听、剧集的提前独家访问以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区的会员资格，请访问 the rest is history.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 the rest is history.com。本集由 Adobe Express 赞助播出，这是一款快捷简便、可创作任何内容的应用程序。这意味着什么？嗯，假设你需要制作一份演示文稿、一个视频、一篇社交媒体帖子或是一份传单，对某些人来说——尤其是对我来说——这听起来让人望而生畏。但汤姆，有了 Adobe Express 直观的功能，比如模板、生成式 AI 和实时协作，一切变得前所未有的简单。Adobe Express。免费试用。在 App Store 中搜索 Adobe Express。
This episode is brought to you by SAP. With investors, customers, and workers demanding more from your business, it's time to try SAP. Its AI-powered capabilities can help you streamline costs, connect with new suppliers, and manage payroll even when your business is being pulled in different directions. To deliver a quality product at a fair price, while paying your people what they're worth, too, so your business can stay unfazed. Learn more at SAP.com slash uncertainty. Agave was foaming at the mouth. Her rolling eyes were wild. She was not in her right mind, but possessed by Bacchus, and she paid no heed to Pentheus.
本集由 SAP 赞助播出。随着投资者、客户和员工对您的企业提出更高要求，是时候尝试 SAP 了。即使您的企业正面临各种不同方向的拉扯，其人工智能驱动的功能也能帮您精简成本、连接新供应商并管理薪资。为了以公平的价格提供优质的产品，同时也给予员工应有的报酬，让您的企业能够处变不惊。了解更多信息，请访问 SAP.com slash uncertainty。阿加维口吐白沫。她转动着野性而疯狂的眼睛。她神志不清，而是被巴克科斯附身，对彭透斯置之不理。
She grasped his left arm between wrist and elbow, set her foot against his ribs, and tore his arm off by the shoulder. It was no strength of hers did it, but the God filled her and made it easy. On the other side, Inoe was at him, tearing at his flesh, and now Outinaway joined them, and the whole maniacal horde. A single and continuous yell arose. Pentheus shrieking as long as life was left in him, the women howling in triumph. One of them carried off an arm, another a foot, the boots still laced on it. The ribs were stripped, clawed clean, and women's hands. thick red with blood were tossing, catching like a plaything, Pentheus's flesh. So that is the devastating climax of the most shocking, the most blood-soaked and notorious
她抓住他的左臂，握在手腕和手肘之间，将脚踩在他的肋骨上，硬生生地把他的手臂从肩膀处撕了下来。这并非靠她自己的力量，而是神灵附在她身上，让她觉得易如反掌。另一边，伊诺扑向他，撕扯着他的血肉，紧接着奥托诺伊也加入了他们，还有那整个狂热的暴民团。尖叫声此起彼伏连绵不断。彭透斯在尚存一息时发出阵阵惨叫，女人们则狂喜地嚎叫着。其中一人带走了一条胳膊，另一人带走了一只脚，靴子还穿在上面。肋骨被剥得精光，被利爪刮得干干净净，女人们血迹斑斑的双手，正像玩物一样抛接、争抢着彭透斯的血肉。这就是那场最令人震惊、最血腥、最臭名昭著的希腊悲剧的高潮，
of all Greek tragedies, the Bacchai by the great Athenian dramatist Euripides. It's a terrible scene. Pentheus is being ripped into pieces by these women possessed with the spirit of Bacchus as he describes it, and the little bits of his flesh are. are left scattered under rocks and over trees. Tom, you chose this lovely reading. Yeah, I did. In the episode.
雅典伟大戏剧家欧里庇得斯的《巴克科斯女祭司》（Bacchai）。这是一个极其恐怖的场景。彭透斯被这些被巴克科斯附身的女性活活撕成了碎片，正如他所描述的那样，他身上的血肉碎片零落。散落在岩石下和树木间。汤姆，你选了这段精彩的朗读。是的，我选了。在本集里。
Why? It's unbelievably dramatic. And it, I mean, it reads like, you know, a kind of description from the walking dead or 28 days later. It has a kind of real zombie vibe. And the scene where this is happening is Mount Kitheron, which is the very same mountain range south of Thebes. in central Greece, where the infant Oedipus in Sophocles' play, which we talked about in the previous
为什么？这戏剧性简直难以置信。而且我的意思是，读起来就像，你知道的，某种来自《行尸走肉》（The Walking Dead）或《惊变28天》（28 Days Later）的描述。它有一种真正的僵尸氛围。发生这一幕的地点是基泰隆山（Mount Kitheron），也就是位于希腊中部底比斯（Thebes）南部的同一座山脉，在索福克利斯（Sophocles）的戏剧中，我们在上一集探讨过，幼年的俄狄浦斯（Oedipus）
episode, was taken from his parents' palace. So generally it's not, it's a place where terrible things happen. But the action in this play, in the back eye, with this poor man being torn to pieces, is set four generations before the time of Oedipus. So Pentheus, the guy who's being torn to pieces, he was the grandfather of Jakasta, who was Edipus's mother, stroke wife. And he ruled as Oedipus was going to rule in due course as the king of Thebes. And we highlighted in the previous episode how the Theban royal family is the most dysfunctional dynasty in the whole of Greek myth. And this episode absolutely sets the seal on this reputation. Because Agave, who you described ripping off Penthes' left arm, is Penthes' mother. Oh my God.
就是从他父母的王宫里被带到这里的。所以总的来说，这是一个可怕事情发生的地方。但在这部戏剧《巴克科斯女祭司》中，这个可怜的人被撕成碎片的行动，发生在俄狄浦斯时代之前整整四代。所以彭透斯，那个被撕成碎片的人，正是俄狄浦斯的母亲兼妻子约卡斯塔（Jocasta）的祖父。他曾经统治底比斯，正如俄狄浦斯随后将要统治的那样。我们在上一集强调过，底比斯王室是整个希腊神话中最不正常的王朝。而这一集绝对为这一声誉盖棺定论了。因为你刚才描述撕下彭透斯左臂的阿加维，正是彭透斯的母亲。天哪。
And I know and Otonoway, who are joining in the fun, are his aunts. So it's, you know, as family rendezvous go, picnics up on the mountain, this is a very, very bad one. And what's going on here is not that they are, you know, you used the Walking Dead parallel. They're not zombies. No. Although in a kind of way they are, they have become possessed, haven't they become ravers, I see in your notes. So what's that? Mynads.
而加入这场狂欢的伊诺和奥托诺伊，是他的阿姨。所以，你可以想象，作为一场家庭聚会、一次山上的野餐，这是一次非常非常糟糕的聚会。这里发生的并不是——你用了《行尸走肉》的比喻——他们不是僵尸。不。虽然在某种程度上他们确实是，他们被附身了，不是吗？他们变成了狂欢者，我在你的笔记里看到了。那是什么？迈纳德（Mynads）。
Mayanad, yes. So they've become what the Greeks called mineads, literally ravers. And they have been gripped by a frenzy that in Greek was called a bacchaya. And when you join a bacchia, if you're a minad, you dress up in the skins of thorns or leopards, and you roam the uplands, you leave the kind of the plains, centres of civilization and go up into the hills. And up there, you either you suckle wild animals. So you put them to your breast. Or, you tear them to pieces with your bare hands. And this is a right of kind of ecstatic dismemberment called Sparagmos in Greek. And if you are a minad who is particularly off her face, then you might go one step further and tear the flesh off your victim and eat it raw, which again the Greeks called omophagia. And the excitement of it is that you are subverted. every norm that governs conventional society in Greece. So you are abandoning your city for the uplands, for the wilds, you're human, but you're
迈纳德，是的。所以他们成了希腊人所说的迈纳德，字面意思就是狂欢者。他们被一种希腊语称为“巴克亚”（bacchaya）的狂热所控制。当你加入一场巴克亚时，如果你是一个迈纳德，你会穿上刺树皮或豹皮，在山地间游荡，离开平原、文明的中心，前往山丘。到了那里，你要么给野生动物哺乳。也就是把它们放在你的胸前。要么，就用双手将它们撕成碎片。这是一种在希腊语中被称为“斯帕格莫斯”（Sparagmos）的狂喜式肢解仪式。如果你是一个特别疯狂的迈纳德，你可能会更进一步，从受害者身上撕下肉并生吃，希腊人称之为“奥莫法吉亚”（omophagia）。这种兴奋感在于，你颠覆了希腊常规社会支配的一切准则。因此，你抛弃了你的城市，走向高地，走向荒野，你是人，但你
turning into a wild beast. And if you're a woman, then you are casting off all the kind of the rules, the assumptions, the decorum that is supposedly govern your behavior. And in the back eye, Euripides describes the mine ads turning men to flight. So men are playing the role of women. So subverting gender norms, as critics would say now. We love doing that on the rest of history. And this is what the Bekehya is all about.
正在变成一头野兽。如果你是一个女人，那么你就是在抛弃所有据说支配你行为的规则、假设和礼仪。在《巴克科斯女祭司》中，欧里庇得斯描述了迈纳德击退男人的情景。所以男人扮演了女人的角色。正如现在的评论家所说，这是在颠覆性别规范。我们很喜欢在《历史的其余部分》里这样做。这就是巴克亚的全部意义所在。
But having said that, it's not just Minads who are doing it. You also get men who are called satires, and the satire has a hint of the goat. David Lloyd George. Yes. Yes. Well, like Lord George, it's this kind of the exciting sense that you're casting off the norms and you can do whatever you like.
话虽如此，不仅是迈纳德在这样做，你还会看到被称为萨提尔（satyrs）的男性，而萨提尔带有山羊的特征。大卫·劳埃德·乔治（David Lloyd George）。是的。是的。嗯，就像劳埃德·乔治一样，这有一种令人兴奋的感觉，即你摆脱了常规，你可以做任何你想做的事。
Yeah. And mynads satires, both are following the same god. And one of the names that this god has is Bacchus, for obvious reasons. He's the god of the Bacchia. He's also known as Omestes, the eater of raw flesh. He has a whole host of other names. But his original name, the name by which the Greeks generally refer to him, is Dionysus. Right. So Dionysus. Of all the Greek gods, Tom, I have to say, I've always found. him the most mysterious and obviously he's the most unsettling because of the rights that are associated with him and we talked previous episodes about how people generally encounter the Greek myths when they're children as children's stories but Dionysus doesn't really fit in them at all when people think of the Olympians he's not one of the names that first comes up but as we'll see as I know you're going to talk about scholars have become
是的。迈纳德和萨提尔，两者都在追随同一个神。这个神的名字之一就是巴克科斯，原因显而易见。他是巴克亚之神。他也被称为奥梅斯特斯（Omestes），生肉吞噬者。他还有一连串其他的名字。但他最初的名字，希腊人通常称呼他的名字，是狄奥尼索斯（Dionysus）。没错。所以在希腊诸神中，汤姆，我必须说，我一直觉得他最神秘，显然也是最让人不安的，因为与他相关的仪式。我们曾在之前的节目中谈到，人们通常在还是孩子的时候作为童话故事初次接触希腊神话，但狄奥尼索斯在其中根本格格不入。当人们想到奥林匹斯山诸神时，他并不是最先浮现的名字之一。但正如我们将要看到的，正如我所知你要谈到的，学者们已经变得
more and more interested in Dionysus yeah in over the last century or so and he's moved from the periphery, really to sort of center stage in historians understandings of the Greeks and their and I was about to say their religion, I know you'll question the word religion, and their experience of the supernatural. Yes, exactly. Yes. Yeah, so Dionysus tends not to feature
越来越对狄奥尼索斯感兴趣了。是的，在过去的一个世纪左右里，他从边缘地位真正走到了历史学家对希腊人及其——我正要说他们的宗教，我知道你会质疑宗教这个词——及其对超自然现象体验理解的舞台中心。没错，绝对是的。是的，所以狄奥尼索斯往往不会出现在
in children's books. And also, he has always been a challenge to those who have an idea of ancient Greece as, you know, a world of serenity and kind of harmony and light and rationalism and all of that. And this was a stereotype of ancient
儿童读物中。而且，对于那些将古希腊视为充满宁静、和谐、光明与理性等特质的世界的人来说，他一直是一个挑战。这是古代的一个刻板印象。
Greece that was very popular, particularly in Germany in the 18th and 19th centuries. So enthusiasts for ancient Greece were always kind of mooning over the noble simplicity and quiet grandeur, as one of them put it, of Greek civilization. But there was a kind of reaction against that bubbling under in 19th century Germany. And the classicist who most famously reacts against it is the great philosopher
希腊在18世纪和19世纪的德国尤为流行。因此，古希腊的狂热爱好者总是带着怀旧之情赞叹希腊文明“高贵的单纯和静穆的伟大”，正如其中一人所说。但在19世纪的德国，暗中涌动着一种针对这种看法的反动思潮。对此反应最著名的古典学者就是伟大的哲学家
Friedrich Nietzsche who oddly ends up talking to a horse in a quite kind of Dionyssen manner. But very early on in his career, long before that, he published a book called The Birth of Tragedy and he was only 28
弗里德里希·尼采（Friedrich Nietzsche），他很不寻常地以一种非常狄奥尼索斯式的方式最终和一匹马说话。但在他职业生涯的非常早期，在那很久之前，他出版了一本名为《悲剧的诞生》（The Birth of Tragedy）的书，当时他年仅28岁
when he did it. He was already a professor of Greek. And essentially, in that book, he is doing for Dionysus, what Freud would do for Oedipus a couple of decades later, kind of make him into, I guess you'd call him a meme now, something, an expression of something that seems simultaneously very ancient, but kind of thrillingly modern, thrillingly 19th century. And what Nietzsche is doing in the birth of tragedy is to contrast Dionysus with Apollo, who, for the Greeks, is the god of light, of beauty. And Nietzsche insists that you can't really understand Greek civilization if you just emphasize the light and the beauty.
他就完成了。当时他已经是希腊语教授了。从本质上讲，在这本书中，他为狄奥尼索斯所做的事情，就像弗洛伊德几十年后为俄狄浦斯所做的一样，基本上把他变成了一个你现在可能会称之为“模因”的东西，一种某种事物的表达，它看起来既非常古老，但又极其现代，极其具有19世纪的色彩。尼采在《悲剧的诞生》中所做的是将狄奥尼索斯与阿波罗进行对比，阿波罗对希腊人来说是光明之神、美丽之神。尼采坚信，如果你仅仅强调光明和美丽，你就无法真正理解希腊文明。
You also have to recognize the deeply Dionysian qualities that Greek civilization had as well. And, you know, I mean, Nietzsche is more than familiar with the Bacchai. The Bacchai plays a key role in the birth of the tragedy. And he, you know, all this kind of tearing people to pieces and things. He says he recognizes the darkness. He said an effusive transgression of the sexual order whose wave swept away all family life and its venerable principles an abominable mixture of sensuality and cruelty.
你还必须承认希腊文明同样具有深刻的狄奥尼索斯特质。而且，你知道，尼采对《巴克科斯女祭司》非常熟悉。《巴克科斯女祭司》在《悲剧的诞生》中扮演了关键角色。而且，你知道，所有这些把人撕成碎片的事情。他说他认识到了黑暗面。他说：“对性秩序的肆意侵犯，其浪潮冲走了所有的家庭生活及其庄严的原则，是感官与残忍的令人发指的结合。”
So he's saying that's a bad thing. Right. Not in favour of that. But then he is also saying that it has, you know, there's a brilliant size to it. Essentially, it's fun, whereas he puts it, the blissful rapture which rises up from the innermost depths of men. I mean, that is German for fun, basically. Right, yeah.
所以他说这是一件坏事。没错。并不赞成这一点。但随后他也表示它有，你知道的，它有辉煌的一面。本质上，它是快乐的，正如他所说，“从人类内心最深处升起的极乐狂喜”。我的意思大致就是德语里的“快乐”，没错，是的。
I'm sure that he expressed that in one word. I'm a large huge German word The essence of the Dionysin, Nietzsche says Basically, it's like getting drunk It's like getting pissed, it's intoxication And Dionysus for the Greeks is the god who invents wine So famously Dionysus is the god of getting drunk But he's also the god
我确信他用一个词表达了这一点。一个巨大的德语长词。狄奥尼索斯的本质，尼采说，基本上，就像喝醉了一样。就像喝得酩酊大醉，那是一种狂喜。对于希腊人来说，狄奥尼索斯是发明葡萄酒的神。因此，众所周知，狄奥尼索斯是醉酒之神，但同时他也是那个神
Who is there when humans experience The thrill of nature that has not been tamed by humans So the thrill of the wild And also, and I think very germainly, and this is part of what Nietzsche found so fascinating about it, and it's certainly what people have found fascinating about it in the 20th century, the sense of ecstasy that you get when you dissolve your own individual sense of yourself into a crowd. A huge theme of 20th century writing and 26th century criticism, right? So, I mean, I know you're going to make a comparison with the 1960s.
当人类体验到未被人类驯服的自然之野性时，他在那里。所以那是对野性的狂热。而且，我认为非常贴切的是——这也是尼采发现它如此迷人的部分原因，而且这无疑也是20世纪人们发现它迷人的原因——当你将自己的独立自我意识融入人群时，你会获得一种狂喜感。这是20世纪写作和26世纪评论的一个巨大主题，对吧？所以，我的意思是，我知道你要把它和20世纪60年代进行比较。
You know, having read loads of sort of countercultural stuff in the 1960s, people were always going on about this, about the joy of Dionysian revels, and that was what the 60s represented, and, you know, that was the spirit, and we were, you know, sort of absolutely reveling in the idea of sort of, that there being something, it is quite a kind of Freudian idea, that there's something deep down buried that needs to be let out, and by drinking or by taking drugs, and by forgetting your individuality and becoming one with your friends, you will express some deeper, more authentic truth. And that's a
你知道，读过大量20世纪60年代的反文化资料后，人们总是在谈论这个，谈论狄奥尼索斯式狂欢的快乐，这就是60年代所代表的，你知道，那就是精神所在，而我们，你知道的，绝对陶醉于这样一种观念，即存在着某种东西，这其实是一个相当弗洛伊德式的想法，即内心深处埋藏着某种需要释放的东西，通过饮酒或吸毒，通过忘记你的个性和你的朋友融为一体，你将表达出某种更深层次、更真实的真理。这是一个
as you say a massive thing in the 60s, but going into rave culture, I mean, a man ad is literally a raver. Yeah. And the idea of going off to a field in Hampshire and taking ease and whiz, this is, you know, you could dignify it by saying this is Dionysin. But there is also kind of a much darker side to Dionysin,
正如你所说，这是60年代的一个重大主题，但进入锐舞文化（rave culture）后，迈纳德字面意思就是一个锐舞派对客。是的。而跑到汉普郡的一个田野里服用摇头丸和安非他命的想法，你可以用说这是狄奥尼索斯式的来为它增光。但狄奥尼索斯也有一个黑暗得多的一面，
the notion of the Dionysen in the 20th century. So there was a seminal study of the Backeye, written by a guy with a splendid name of R. P. Winnington Ingram, which came out in 1947, so immediately after the Second World War called Euripides and Dionysus, Winnington Ingram had witnessed the Nuremberg rallies. And in the introduction to his book, he wrote, we have lived through events which have demonstrated tragically the dangers of group emotion. He doesn't specify what it is,
即20世纪对狄奥尼索斯概念的理解。因此，有一项关于《巴克科斯女祭司》的开创性研究，由一个名字非常响亮的人 R. P. 威宁顿·英格姆（R. P. Winnington-Ingram）所著，出版于1947年，也就是第二次世界大战刚结束时，书名为《欧里庇得斯与狄奥尼索斯》（Euripides and Dionysus）。威宁顿·英格姆曾亲眼目睹纽伦堡集会。他在书的引言中写道：“我们经历了一些悲剧性地证明了群体情感危险性的事件。”他没有具体说明是什么事件，
but in 1947, everyone knows what he's referring to. And so you can see why the idea of the Dionysen, I mean, it's a very powerful one, because if it can embrace both, you know, the counterculture of the 60s and the Nuremberg rallies, you know, you're covering a lot of bases there. And I think that although today classicists do not accept the kind of the precise details of the technical arguments that Nietzsche goes into in the birth of tragedy, what they do accept is his broader case, which is that Dionysus has a really central role in Greek civilization, in Greek culture and more generally the irrational. Right.
但在1947年，每个人都知道他指的是什么。所以你可以理解为什么狄奥尼索斯的理念——我的意思是，这是一个非常强大的理念，因为如果它既能包容60年代的反文化，又能包容纽伦堡集会，你知道，那你就涵盖了很多方面。我认为，尽管今天的古典学者不接受尼采在《悲剧的诞生》中所探讨的技术论点的精确细节，但他们接受了他更广泛的观点，即狄奥尼索斯在希腊文明、希腊文化以及更广泛的非理性领域中扮演着真正核心的角色。没错。
You know, there's a famous book by E.R. Dodds, the Greeks and the irrational. I mean, even Apollo, I mean, Apollo is counterpointed to Dionysus by Nietzsche. But Apollo is an absolute bastard as well. I mean, you know, he's killing everyone left, right and center, too. So the sense of the dark and the strange and the weird and the ecstatic is crucially a part of Greek mythology. But a Greek myth, but not of the legends, right? So here's the thing.
你知道，E.R. 多兹（E.R. Dodds）有一本著名的书《希腊人与非理性》（The Greeks and the Irrational）。我的意思是，即使是阿波罗，尼采将阿波罗与狄奥尼索斯进行对比，但阿波罗也是个绝对的混蛋。我的意思是，你知道，他也在左右开弓地杀人。因此，黑暗、奇异、怪诞和狂喜的感觉，至关重要地是希腊神话的一部分。但它是希腊神话的一部分，而不是那些传奇故事的一部分，对吧？所以问题就在这里。
A lot of people, when they saw we were doing a series about Greek myth, would have been like, oh, they're going to do Heracles, they're going to do Perseus, they're going to, oh, Dionysus, that's a slightly niche one to choose. And is that because Dionysus, he doesn't really feature in a lot of the kind of canonical stories? Now, why is that? Why is he, is he even mentioned in the Iliad at all? There are very fleeting references to him by Homer, by Hesiod, and he's not a central figure in any way, as you say.
许多人在看到我们正在做一个关于希腊神话的系列节目时，会觉得：“哦，他们要讲海格力斯（Heracles），他们要讲珀尔修斯（Perseus），他们要讲……哦，狄奥尼索斯，选这个稍微有点小众。”这是因为狄奥尼索斯在很多经典故事中并不怎么出场吗？现在，这是为什么呢？为什么他——他在《伊利亚特》（Iliad）中甚至被提及了吗？荷马和赫西奥德（Hesiod）对他的提及非常短暂，正如你所说，他在任何方面都不是一个核心人物。
And that is crucially important, because as we've said already, the Greek understanding of the gods is mediated by poets, not by priests. or prophets. What about temples? Are the temples to him? Not many temples either. And in fact, as happens in the plot of the Backeye, Dionysus seems much keener on kind of pulling temples down than having them erected to him.
这至关重要，因为正如我们已经说过的那样，希腊人对神灵的理解是通过诗人来传达的，而不是通过祭司或先知。神庙呢？有供奉他的神庙吗？神庙也不多。事实上，正如《巴克科斯女祭司》的剧情中所发生的那样，狄奥尼索斯似乎更热衷于拆除神庙，而不是让人为他建造神庙。
And I think a further reason why Dionysus seems slightly at the margins of the kind of conventional understanding of Greek myth is that he is conventionally portrayed as a very young god, kind of very youthful. and he is also described as coming from beyond Greece and particularly from the East. So in the Backeye, for instance, Dionysus describes himself as arriving in Thebes from Asia, the fields of Lydia and Fridia, fertile in gold.
我认为狄奥尼索斯似乎处于对希腊神话传统理解之边缘的另一个原因是，他传统上被描绘成一个非常年轻的神，非常青春洋溢，并且他还被描述为来自希腊之外，特别是东方。例如，在《巴克科斯女祭司》中，狄奥尼索斯将自己描述为从亚洲、富产黄金的吕底亚（Lydia）和弗里吉亚（Phrygia）的土地抵达底比斯。
And Winnington Ingram in that book, which published in 1947, he completely takes for granted that Dionysus is a very recent import, that he's only just come to Greece. And this is why he's not really mentioned by Homer or by Hesiod. but actually our understanding of who Dionysus is has been completely transformed since the 1940s because in the 1950s tablets from the Mycenaean citadles in Greece and from Crete were cracked and these kind of very ancient tablets and it revealed that actually Dionysus is one of the oldest Olympians and he has a temple on one of the islands in the Aegean that has been dated
而威宁顿·英格姆在那本出版于1947年的书中，理所当然地认为狄奥尼索斯是一个非常晚近的舶来品，他才刚刚来到希腊。这就是为什么荷马或赫西奥德没有真正提及他的原因。但实际上，自20世纪40年代以来，我们对狄奥尼索斯是谁的理解已经被彻底颠覆了，因为在20世纪50年代，希腊迈锡尼城堡和克里特岛的泥板被破译了，这些极其古老的泥板表明，实际上狄奥尼索斯是奥林匹斯山最古老的神祇之一，并且他在爱琴海的一个岛屿上拥有一座可以追溯到
as far back as the 15th century BC so he is actually, you know, I mean, he's, he, he's been part of the Greek imagination for a very, very long time. And although he's kind of hazy, perhaps in the public imagining as a figure of myth, and although his cult does seem weird and strange when compared to the, the cults of other gods, he is no less Greek than Apollo. And that's basically what, you know, what Nietzsche had kind of intuited. And so his strangeness is not, you know, it's not a bug. It's an absolute feature. It's there at the heart of Greek culture right from the very beginning. Well, let's try to tell his story a little bit. So obviously, the fact that he's not
早在公元前15世纪，所以他实际上，你知道，我的意思是，他，他，他长久以来一直是希腊想象的一部分。尽管他在大众对神话人物的想象中也许有些模糊，而且与其它神的崇拜相比，他的崇拜确实显得怪异和奇特，但他绝不逊色于阿波罗。这基本上就是尼采所直觉到的。因此，他的怪异并非什么漏洞，绝对是个特征。它从一开始就存在于希腊文化的核心。好吧，让我们试着讲讲他的故事。很显然，他没有
covered by these great poets, or he's not really covered in the same detail, means that it's harder to piece together, to create a canonical story for him, as we did for, you know, you told the story of Zeus, for example. You could do it with Hermes or Apollo or whoever. Now, there are lots of different rival traditions, aren't there? So one of them is that the Titans tore him apart and then they et him and then they put him back together which strikes me it's kind of drawing on the rituals
被这些伟大的诗人们所涉猎，或者没有以同样的详细程度被涉猎，这意味着很难拼凑出关于他的正统故事，正如我们对……例如，你讲过宙斯的精神那样。你可以用赫尔墨斯、阿波罗或任何人来做这件事。现在，有许多不同的对立传统，不是吗？其中一个传统是泰坦们把他撕碎，然后吃掉了他，接着又把他重新拼凑起来，这让我觉得有点借鉴了那些仪式的成分
that he's associated with and then the other is that he's the son of Zeus and Persephone who's the queen of the underworld which one of those do you go for or do you go for neither okay for all of them and bear in mind that Persephone was Zeus's daughter
与他有关的仪式，而另一个传统则是他是宙斯和冥界女王珀耳塞福涅的儿子。你倾向于哪一个，还是两个都不选，或者两个都选？记住，珀耳塞福涅是宙斯的女儿
yeah okay yeah by his sister so there's a whole load of incest going on there. There's a lot going on there. And there's also, there were traditions that there were actually two gods called Dionysus. So essentially, I think what you have is that the stories told of Dionysus are like, you know, haze of smoke. It's impossible to get a finger on them. They're always kind of drifting away. But having said that, in Thebes, there is a very distinctive tradition. And it, it derives from the one significance reference to Dionysus that we do get
是的，好吧，也就是他妹妹的女儿，所以那里存在着大量的乱伦。有很多错综复杂的关系。而且还有一些传统认为实际上有两个名叫狄俄尼索斯的 thần。所以基本上，我认为关于狄俄尼索斯的那些故事就像……你知道的，一团迷雾。根本无法确切指明它们。它们总是飘忽不定。话虽如此，在底比斯，有一个非常独特的传统。它源于我们唯一能找到的关于狄俄尼索斯的明确记载
in Hesiod. So we talked about him in the first episode. He wrote a, um, uh, uh, a poem called the theogony that discusses where the gods came from. And to the extent that there is a kind of canonical account of the origins of the gods, Hesiod provides it. And so what Hesiod has to say about Dionysus, even though it's very fleeting, has a lot of weight. So what Hesiod said, Cadmus's daughter, Semile, Bord's use, a resplendent son in shared intimacy, Mary Dionysus, immortal son of mortal mother. And Cadmus, who we talked about in the previous episode, Sowing dragon's teeth. Sowing dragon's teeth.
赫西俄德的作品。所以在第一集中我们讨论过他。他写过一首题为《神谱》的诗，探讨了诸神从何而来。在某种程度上，存在着一种关于诸神起源的正统说法，而赫西俄德就提供了这种说法。因此，赫西俄德对狄俄尼索斯的描述，尽管转瞬即逝，却有着巨大的分量。赫西俄德是这么说的：卡德姆斯的女儿塞墨勒在欢愉的亲密中为宙斯生下一个光芒四射的儿子，荣耀的狄俄尼索斯，一个由凡人母亲生下的不朽之子。卡德姆斯，我们在上一集中讨论过他，他播撒了龙牙。播撒了龙牙。
The Phoenician prince, who had gone to look for his sister, Europa, never finds her, comes to Thebes and founds Thebes. He is the father of Agave, the mother of Pentheus, who tears him to pieces. And that means that Pentheus, the son of Agave, is the cousin of Dionysus. So very much a family affair. Very much a family affair. And this is the story that Euripides, who is in Athens, you know, just down the road from Thieves, is drawing on for the opening of the Bacai. So the play opens with Dionysus himself. He's standing on the stage, and he announces to the watching audience who he is.
这位腓尼基王子曾去寻找他的妹妹欧罗巴，却再也没有找到她，随后他来到底比斯并建了底比斯。他是阿加韦的父亲，而阿加韦正是彭透斯的母亲，彭透斯后来被撕成了碎片。这意味着阿加韦的儿子彭透斯就是狄俄尼索斯的表亲。这绝对是一桩家族事务。绝对是一桩家族事务。这就是在雅典的欧里庇得斯（就在底比斯不远）在创作《巴凯》开场时所借鉴的故事。所以戏剧一开场就是狄俄尼索斯本人。他站在舞台上，向观看演出的观众宣布他是谁。
I am Dionysus, son of Zeus, my mother, with Semele, Cadmus' daughter, from her womb, the fire of a lightning flash delivered me. And as so often in tragedy, we don't get the full story because the playwright is assuming that the audience already knows it. And the reason that Euripides can assume that people know this is because another famous playwright, called Eeschylus had actually written a celebrated play about exactly this drama. And so as far as we can tell, the story that is told in Thebes and then recycled by the Athenian tragedians about the birth of Dionysus in Thebes goes as follows. So Zemile is a priestess of Zeus in Thebes and she's very beautiful. And so inevitably she attracts the attention of Zeus, who transforms himself into an eagle and repeatedly descends on her
我是狄俄尼索斯，宙斯之子。我的母亲塞墨勒，卡德姆斯的女儿，从她的腹中，闪电的烈火将我孕育并带到人间。正如悲剧中所常见的那样，我们无法得知完整的故事情节，因为剧作家默认观众已经了解这些。而欧里庇得斯之所以能假定人们知道这一切，是因为另一位著名的剧作家埃斯库罗斯曾写过一部广受赞誉的戏剧，讲述的正是这段戏剧。因此据我们所知，关于狄俄尼索斯在底比斯出生的故事在底比斯广为流传，后来又被雅典的悲剧作家们反复演绎，其内容如下。塞墨勒底比斯的一名宙斯女祭司，她非常美丽。因此，她不可避免地吸引了宙斯的注意。宙斯化身为一只鹰，一次次降临到她身旁
and very rapidly gets her pregnant with Dionysus and it's evident from the beginning that Dionysus is something special because you only have to touch Semelais's pregnant belly and you were driven into a kind of ecstatic madness. Hera, the wife of Zeus, relentlessly jealous, understandably because of Zeus's record of philandering. She finds out about this and it's a slightly kind of snow white in the Disney film vibe.
并很快让她怀上了狄俄尼索斯。从一开始就很明显，狄俄尼索斯绝非寻常之辈，因为你只需触碰塞墨勒怀孕的腹部，就会陷入一种狂喜的疯狂之中。宙斯的妻子赫拉，嫉妒心极强，考虑到宙斯风流成性的历史，这也情有可原。她发现了这件事，这有点像迪士尼电影里《白雪公主》的感觉。
She transforms herself into an old crone and she visits Semelais and she says, you know, you think that this eagle coming every night is Zeus, but I mean, how do you know? Are you sure about this? And Semelay starts to worry about this and says, well, how can I find out? And Hera says, the only way that you can know it is Zeus is if you ask him to reveal himself in the full refulgent glory of his divine splendor. And Semley says, okay, well, that's, I'll do that. And so she's, she's in bed with Zeus.
她把自己变成了一个老太婆，去拜访了塞墨勒，对她说：“你知道的，你以为每天晚上来的这只鹰是宙斯，但我的意思是，你怎么知道？你对此确信不疑吗？”塞墨勒开始为此感到担忧，并说：“那我该怎么弄清楚呢？”赫拉回答说：“要知道他是不是宙斯的唯一办法，就是请求他以神圣光辉的全部炫目光彩向你显现。”塞墨勒说：“好吧，那我就这么做。”于是，她和宙斯躺在床上
I don't know whether he's turned into her. Yeah, Zeus or whether he's still an eagle. I mean, stroking his feathers or whatever. And she says, darling, promise me something. And Zeus says, I promise you whatever. And Semley says, absolutely swear it solemnly. You cannot break it. And Zeus says, fine.
我不知道他是变回了人形，还是依然是一只鹰。我的意思是，抚摸着他的羽毛之类的。然后她对她说：“亲爱的，答应我一件事。”宙斯说：“我什么都答应你。”塞墨勒说：“一定要庄严地发誓。你绝不能违背。”宙斯说：“好吧。”
And then somebody says, I want you, if you are Zeus, to show me. your full glory and Zeus desperately tries to back out of it you know trying to say please don't make me do this but Semelay insists and so Zeus has no choice and he reveals himself this kind of scorching blaze it's like looking into the heart of um I don't know an atom bomb going off or something it completely shrivels and destroys Semelay and she's left as kind of charred smoldering ash and Zeus picks up the unborn baby who's been left undamaged by this. manifestation, and he sows the fetus into his thigh, and then a few weeks later, Dionysus is born. So a very implausible story your father would probably describe it as. He would. But this is
然后塞墨勒说：“如果你真的是宙斯，我希望你向我展示。你全部的光辉。”宙斯拼命想要退缩，试图说：“请不要让我这么做。”但塞墨勒坚持不放，所以宙斯别无选择，只能显现出他那种炽热的烈火，就像凝视着……我不知道，一颗原子炸弹爆炸的核心之类的情形。它彻底将塞墨勒烤焦并摧毁了，她只剩下一堆焦黑、冒烟的灰烬。宙斯捡起了那个未出生的婴儿，这个婴儿在这场显圣中完好无损，并把这个胎儿缝进了自己的大腿里。几周后，狄俄尼索斯出生了。你父亲可能会把这描述为一个非常荒诞的故事。
what the Thebans absolutely thought had happened. This is the story that is being invoked at the start of Euripides' play, because Dionysus describes in it how his mother's house smolders with the still living flame of Zeus's fire. And Dionysus notes approvingly that Cadmus, who is still alive, so the very, by this point, aged founder of Thebes, has consecrated the House of Semmelay as as holy, as sacred to the gods. And Dionysus himself boasts of having decked it round with sprays of young vine leaves. So the vine, of course, is holy to Dionysus. Yeah. So that's Thebes, but there are Athenian traditions as well, aren't there? They're kind of rivaled traditions, because the Athenians say, okay, fine, you know, he was born in Thebes, but he came to Athens,
他确实会这么说。但这就是底比斯人绝对深信不疑的事情。这就是欧里庇得斯戏剧开场时所引用的故事，因为狄俄尼索斯在其中描述了他母亲的房子如何冒着宙斯之火那依然炽热的余烬。狄俄尼索斯赞许地指出，至今仍然健在的底比斯年迈创立者卡德姆斯，已经将塞墨勒的宅邸奉为圣地，献给诸神。狄俄尼索斯本人也吹嘘说，他已经用嫩葡萄藤的枝条将它环绕装饰了一番。当然，葡萄藤对狄俄尼索斯来说是神圣的。是的。这就是底比斯，但雅典也有相关传统，不是吗？它们算是一种对立的传统，因为雅典人会说，好吧，行吧，你知道的，他是在底比斯出生的，但他来到了雅典
and they have a festival celebrates it, don't they? The Antheistaria, which is held in the spring. It is, as is the way with Dionysus, it's simultaneously ecstatically joyous and deeply, deeply unsettling. So the fun side first, essentially the Antheistaria is a kind of great communal celebration, and all of Dionysus' festivals are communal. It's all about the ecstasy. of becoming part of a huge crowd, and it marks the opening and the drinking of the previous years vintage. And everybody in Athens chairs in this. So slaves share in it, and women who
他们有一个庆祝这个的节日，对吧？安蒂斯特里亚节，在春天举行。正如狄俄尼索斯的一贯风格，它既充满令人狂喜的欢乐，又有着深深的、令人不安的诡异。先说有趣的一面，本质上安蒂斯特里亚节是一场盛大的集体庆祝活动，狄俄尼索斯的所有节日都是集体的。这全关乎融入巨大群体之中的狂喜，它标志着前一年佳酿的开封和饮用。雅典的每个人都参与其中。奴隶们也参与其中，还有那些
normally are discouraged from drinking wine, they also are, they can have a tipple. And it's great fun. There's a huge procession. Dionysus is escorted into Athens from Piraeus, the port, and a cart, and this cart has been made up to look like a ship as the cart is led into Athens it's surrounded by huge fallacies and the whole celebration is inspired by a famous poem that describes Dionysus' victory over pirates the pirates are taking Dionysus as a passenger
平时不鼓励饮酒的女性，她们也可以小酌一杯。这非常有趣。有一场盛大的游行。狄俄尼索斯从港口比雷埃夫斯被护送进入雅典，乘坐一辆花车，这辆花车被装扮成一艘船的模样。当花车被引领进雅典时，周围环绕着巨大的阳具雕像，整个庆祝活动灵感来自于一首著名的诗，该诗描述了狄俄尼索斯战胜海盗的故事。海盗们把狄俄尼索斯当作乘客
they try to kidnap him and murder him and Dionysus turns into a lion and as he does so vines start to grow out from the mast and to wrap the tendrils wrap around the rigging and then the oars and everything and all the pirates are turned into dolphins. Just on the festival, this is a very boring and banal question, sorry, but you said Dionysus is escorted into the city in a cart, decorated sort of like a ship.
他们试图绑架并谋杀他，而狄俄尼索斯则变成了一根狮子，与此同时，葡萄藤开始从桅杆上长出来，卷须缠绕在索具上，然后是船桨以及所有东西，所有的海盗都变成了海豚。顺便说到这个节日，这是一个非常无聊且平庸的问题，对不起，但你刚才说狄俄尼索斯被一辆装扮得像船一样的花车护送进城。
When you say Dionysus, do you mean a statue, is that an effigy of doing someone playing the part? We will come to exactly who Dionysus is in this celebration in a minute. I mean, you're absolutely right to fix on that, because the thing that is representing Dianysus is incredibly interesting and then ties into the second festival that we'll be talking about. Exciting. But just sticking to the Anfesteria at the moment, this idea of a great festival of Dionysus arriving in a city is clearly something that Euripides is echoing in the back eye. And the other thing that he is echoing in the back eye is the absolutely central role in this festival that is played by women. So there is a band of women who are called the venerable ones. So presumably they're kind of more elderly. They are appointed. to make a nighttime sacrifice to Dionysus in one of the few temples that have been erected to him. But it's telling that this temple is not in the city, it's out in the marshes.
当你提到狄俄尼索斯时，你是说一尊雕像吗？那是一个模拟的木偶，还是有人在扮演这个角色？我们一会儿就会讲到在这个庆祝活动中究竟谁代表了狄俄尼索斯。我的意思是，你抓住这一点是完全正确的，因为代表狄俄尼索斯的事物极其有趣，并且与我们要讨论的第二个节日息息相关。太令人兴奋了。不过就目前而言，我们还是专注于安蒂斯特里亚节。狄俄尼索斯抵达某个城市这一盛大节日的概念，显然是欧里庇得斯在《巴凯》中遥相呼应的。他在《巴凯》中呼应的另一件事是，女性在这个节日中扮演了绝对核心的角色。有一群被称为“尊贵者”的女性。所以推测她们年纪稍长一些。她们被指派
And it is only ever opened during this festival. And they all go out there. And one of them who has been appointed queen of the venerable ones, then we are told, has sex with Dionysus. And what exactly that means, I mean, we will never know. We have no idea what that actually means. but there are illustrations on vases made in Athens that shows the venerable ones at this shrine out in the marshes and they're drinking and they're dancing
在仅有的几座为他修建的庙宇之一中，向狄俄尼索斯献上夜间祭品。但很有说明意义的是，这座庙宇不在城里，而是在沼泽地带。
and they're making sacrifice before the idol of Dionysus and this idol Dominic, this is what you were asking about, it's very primitive, it's not the kind of, you know, the glowing sculpture that you would get in the museum today. It's not what you kind of imagine as a Greek statue. It's essentially a pole with a mask hanging from it. How would you have carnal relations with a mask?
而且它只在这个节日期间开放。她们全都到那儿去。据说其中一位被推选为“尊贵者”女王的人，随后与狄俄尼索斯发生了性关系。具体这意味着什么，我的意思是，我们永远不会知道。我们根本不知道那究竟意味着什么。但在雅典制作的花瓶上有插图显示了“尊贵者”们在沼泽地带的那座神龛前饮酒跳舞
Well, it's a mask hanging from a pole. So who knows what's on the pole? Yeah, the pole. But I mean, the mask, what part of that? Anyway, I'm overthinking it. I'm not overthinking it. You're not overthinking it because it is an intriguing question. And if you've got a festival with huge fallacies, I mean, we don't know.
并在狄俄尼索斯的偶像前献祭。这个偶像，多米尼克，这就是你刚才问的，非常原始，它可不是那种你在如今博物馆里能看到的熠熠生辉的雕塑。它跟你想象中的希腊雕像完全不同。本质上，它只是一根挂着面具的柱子。你怎么能和一个面具发生肉体关系呢？
And I think lots of Greeks didn't know. I mean, that was part of the fascination of what were these women getting up to in their temple. I mean, and so you can see that it would. would, as with us, kind of inspire all kinds of male fantasies and questions that is then part of the context for what Euripides is doing. And that mask, from the evidence of Athenian pottery, which is really the only evidence that we have, does seem from very ancient times to have been specifically associated with Dionysus. And the mask plays a key role in the other great festival that is celebrated in Athens. And in this festival, the huge mass,
嗯，这是一个挂在柱子上的面具。所以谁知道柱子上有什么呢？对，柱子。但我的意思是，那个面具，这部分的究竟是……不管怎样，我有点过度解读了。我没有过度解读。你没有过度解读，因为这确实是一个耐人寻味的问题。如果你有一个伴随着巨型阳具雕像的节日，我的意思是，我们并不知道。
of the city's male citizens assemble in a theatre on the slopes below the Acropolis to watch the staging of myths by actors who are wearing masks and this is a festival called the Great Dionysia and it was staged in late spring
我想许多希腊人也不知道。我的意思是，这就是这些女性在她们的庙宇里究竟在干什么所带来的魅力的一部分。所以你可以看出，这将会像对我们一样，激发各种男性的幻想和疑问，而这也正是欧里庇得斯当时所处背景的一部分。根据雅典陶器的证据（这确实是我们拥有的唯一证据），那个面具从远古时代起似乎就与狄俄尼索斯有着明确的联系。在雅典庆祝的另一个盛大节日中，面具扮演了关键角色。在这个节日里，巨大的群体
and unlike the Anthisteria it's of relatively recent origin so the late 6th century BC Anthropesiria origins reach back centuries and centuries this festival is inaugurated while Athens is still under the rule of tyrants
城里的大多数男性公民聚集在卫城下方斜坡上的剧院里，观看由戴着面具的演员上演的神话故事。这是一个名为“伟大的狄俄尼索斯节”的节日，它在春末上演
but the tyrants get expelled, the democracy is founded. And this festival, and particularly the acting out of stories by people wearing masks, becomes a key part of the culture of democratic Athens. It has at its heart this amazing cultural innovation that the Athenians call drama. Right. So that obviously includes tragedy, but it also includes comedy, and it includes things called satire plays and these are plays that have satires
与安蒂斯特里亚节不同，它的起源相对较晚，大约在公元前6世纪末。而安蒂斯特里亚节的起源可以追溯到几个世纪前。这个节日是在雅典仍然受暴君统治时创立的
so the male followers of Dionysus as a chorus. That's its own genre. Satire play. How any of them survived? Yeah. We have fragments of it. Tony Harrison kind of wrote one
但暴君被驱逐了，民主制建立了。这个节日，特别是人们戴着面具将故事演绎出来，成为了民主雅典文化的核心部分。它的核心是一项令人惊叹的文化创新，雅典人称之为戏剧。没错。所以这显然包括悲剧，但也包括喜剧，还包括被称为萨堤尔剧的剧种，这些剧里都有萨堤尔
that gives you people a sense of what it might have been like. Right. Was it good? Yeah. I mean, if you like a satire play. Yeah. Actually, I mean, I don't like it.
也就是作为歌队的狄俄尼索斯的男性追随者。这是一个独立的流派。萨堤尔剧。其中有任何幸存下来的吗？是的。我们有它的残篇。托尼·哈里森曾写过一部
I don't know anything. about satire plays, so I don't know if I'd like it to give it a go. Open-minded. Yeah, I'm very open-minded. You know me. So you've got your satire plays. They're clearly Dionysin. But actually, the tragedies and comedies, even though they don't always, I mean, most of the surviving ones don't have Dionysus at its centre. Nevertheless, it's clear, I think, that the whole festival is very, very Dionysin. So to quote Richard Seaford, who wrote a excellent book on Dionysus, The drama festival was performed in a sanctuary of Dionysus, along with rituals for Dionysus, during a festival of Dionysus. And on top of that, Dionysus is viewed as one of the key sources for poetic inspiration.
能让人们大致了解它可能是什么样子的作品。好吧。它好看吗？是的。我的意思是，如果你喜欢萨堤尔剧的话。实际上，我的意思是，我不喜欢。
I think we can conclude from that that Dionysus definitely had a part to play in drama. He absolutely does. And also think about the communal nature of it. Right. Oh, yeah. The crowd. The audience. Huge, huge numbers of people gathering.
我对萨堤尔剧一无所知，所以我不知道自己会不会喜欢它，不妨一试。思想开放。是的，我很思想开放。你了解我的。所以你有你的萨堤尔剧。它们显然具有狄俄尼索斯的特色。但实际上，悲剧和喜剧，尽管它们并不总是——我的意思是，大多数幸存的作品并没有把狄俄尼索斯放在中心位置。尽管如此，我认为很明显，整个节日都具有非常非常浓厚的狄俄尼索斯色彩。借用理查德·西福德（他写过一本关于狄俄尼索斯的优秀著作）的话说：“戏剧节是在狄俄尼索斯的圣殿里，伴随着对狄俄尼索斯的仪式，在狄俄尼索斯的节日期间演出的。”除此之外，狄俄尼索斯还被视为诗歌灵感的重要来源之一。
Do women attend? We're never told that they don't. but probably not, there's probably not room for them. I mean, maybe a priestess or two there, but probably this is a, you know, it's the mass of the male citizens who are there. And they're sitting down to watch stories that may not feature Dionysus himself, but these stories tend to have themes that echo stories that are told about Dionysus. So, royal dynasties tearing themselves to pieces.
我想我们可以从中得出结论，狄俄尼索斯在戏剧中绝对扮演了一定的角色。他确实如此。还要想想它的集体性质。对，哦，是的。人群。观众。数量极其庞大的人们聚集在一起。
So you get that in Oedipus, for instance. Yeah. Dramatic moments of revelation, dramatic moments where fortunes are upended and reversed, and the downfall of someone who thinks to defy the gods while a chorus watches on. So all of that you get in Oedipus. But what you get in the back eye is Dionysus himself. So he is there nakedly, you know, for the Greeks, it's the equivalent of drinking wine unmixed with water. Yeah. If you think about a conventional tragedy, Dionysus isn't present. That's the watered down wine. If you have Dionysus at the center of the tragedy, that is like drinking neat wine. And
女性会出席吗？我们从没听说她们不出席，但大概不会，可能没有她们的空间。我的意思是，也许有一两位女祭司在那里，但这可能是一个……你知道的，是在场的广大男性公民。他们坐下来观看那些可能没有狄俄尼索斯本人出场的戏剧，但这些故事往往有着与狄俄尼索斯相关的故事相呼应的主题。例如，王室家族自相残杀。
The Greeks tended not to do that because they knew that it was incredibly dangerous. Oh, it's exciting. So we've got to the neat wine. It is powerful. It's intoxicating. It's dangerous. And that is the back eye. And we're going to be asking the second half, why and when was it staged when it was?
希腊人往往不会那样做，因为他们知道这极其危险。哦，这太刺激了。所以我们来到了纯酒。它是强烈的。它是令人陶醉的。它是危险的。这就是《巴克科斯女祭司》。而我们在后半部分要探讨的是，它为什么以及什么时候会以这种方式上演？
What did people think of it? What on earth was the point of it? What did people think of it when they first saw it? And how does it point towards an excitingly radical interpretation of myth, Tom? I'm just reading from your notes here. Yeah. You're doing it brilliantly. Yeah.
人们是怎么看待它的？这到底有什么意义？人们第一次看到它时作何感想？汤姆，它又是如何指向一种对神话的令人兴奋的激进诠释的？我这正是在读你的笔记呢。没错。你讲得太棒了。没错。
One that continues to influence how we tend to conceptualize the world to this day. I don't think we've ever had a more exciting cliffhanger. So come back in a minute. Dole it, can I just say, I mean, you could give it more welly, because it really is exciting. What is happening in Athens at this point, and the back eye is channeling it, is something that is going to profoundly affect the way that the Greeks understand the world, but also continues to influence the way that we understand the world to this. day. So after the break, probably the most important half hour of your lives, like a half
它继续影响着我们直到今天对世界的概念化方式。我想我们从来没有过如此扣人心弦的悬念。所以请过一会儿再回来。多尔，请允许我说，我的意思是，你可以更有激情一点，因为这真的很刺激。此时此刻雅典正在发生的事情，而《巴克科斯女祭司》正在传达的，将深刻影响希腊人理解世界的方式，而且它也继续影响着我们直到今天理解世界的方式。所以在中场休息之后，这可能是你们一生中最重要半小时，就像是一场
hour of Tom Holland chat that will change the way you see the world, you see the Greeks that you understand the meaning of your own life and your purpose on this earth. Come back after the ads, or if you remember the rest of history club, plunge in right away to this intoxicating bath of undiluted wine and blood. This episode is brought. to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most? We all need that sometimes, and Uber knows it. Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered. It's showing up no matter what. Like for your long distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick,
半小时的汤姆·霍尔顿聊天，它将改变你看待世界的方式、你看待希腊人的方式、让你理解自己生命的意义以及你在地球上的目标。广告之后回来，或者如果你是“历史其余部分”俱乐部（The Rest is History Club）的会员，那就立刻沉浸到这杯由纯葡萄酒和鲜血交织而成的迷醉之浴中吧。本集由Uber赞助播出。嘿，你知道当有人在你最需要的时候出现的那种感觉吗？我们有时都需要那样，Uber深知这一点。Uber不只是提供一次行程或送一份餐。它是不论如何都会出现。就像为你的异地朋友，在他们生病时送上汤，
sending flowers when they're down. When it really matters, whatever it is, you show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber. on our way. Download the app today. Welcome back to the rest is history. I can only imagine the excitement and the tension as people look forward to this, the most thrilling 25 minutes of content we will ever produce. 25 minutes that will probably change all our lives because Tom really wanted to give this some wellie because he thinks it's so important. It's the back eye. It's you rip. Eurpedes's play, it was first staged in 405 BC, and even then, did people know how important
在他们失落时送上鲜花。当真正重要的时候，无论是什么，你都会出现。只要有心，我们就在路上。Uber，在路上。今天就下载应用程序吧。欢迎回到“历史其余部分”。我只能想象当人们期待这个时那份激动与紧张，这是我们制作过最惊心动魄的25分钟内容。这25分钟可能会改变我们所有人的生活，因为汤姆真的想充满激情地讲讲这个，因为他觉得这太重要了。这就是《巴克科斯女祭司》。这是欧里庇得斯的戏剧，它于公元前405年首次上演，即便在当时，人们是否知道这会在多年后对“历史其余部分”的听众如此重要？我不知道。也许他们知道吧。不，我想这并不是他们最关心的事。不。因为在公元前405年，他们在想别的事情。他们绝对在想别的事情。所以这是一部生后上演的戏剧。根据传统，欧里庇得斯在前一年死于马其顿。一年后，也就是公元前404年的春天，
this would be all these years later for listeners to the rest of history? I don't know. Maybe they did. No, I don't think that was uppermost in their minds. No. Because in 405 BC, they think about other things. They absolutely are thinking about other things. So it is a posthumously produced play. Euripides had died the previous year, according to tradition, in Macedon. And one year later, so in the spring of 404 BC. Athens is going to surrender to Sparta. So we talked in the previous episode, there's been this great war that's been raging since 431 BC. Athens is on the brink of defeat and when the defeat comes, it is absolutely total. So everybody who is taking a seat to watch the back eye when it is premiered knows what they're staring down the barrel on. They're staring down the barrel,
雅典将向斯巴达投降。所以我们在上一集里聊过，这场大战自公元前431年以来一直在肆虐。雅典正处于战败的边缘，而当战败降临时，它是绝对彻底的。所以每一个在首映时落座观看《巴克科斯女祭司》的人，都清楚他们正面临着怎样的绝境。他们面临的绝境，
not just of defeat, but of potential annihilation. Their city could be flattened to the ground by the Spartans. And so I think that that raises two obvious questions. And the first is, what exactly were they watching that spring morning of 405 BC? And then secondly, how did it impact them, bearing in mind what the horrible political context was? OK, let's start with the plot. So what are they watching? What's the story? So we've described how Dionysus arrives and tells the audience who he is. He has come from across the sea, but his own family have rejected him. And part of the reason for that is that although he has revealed himself as divine to the audience,
不仅仅是战败，还有潜在的灭顶之灾。他们的城市可能会被斯巴达人夷为平地。所以我想这就引出了两个显而易见的问题。第一个是，在公元前405年那个春天的早晨，他们到底在看什么？第二个是，考虑到当时可怕的政治背景，这对他们产生了什么影响？好吧，让我们从剧情开始。所以他们在看什么？故事是什么？所以我们已经描述了狄奥尼索斯如何到来并告诉观众他是谁。他从海的那头走来，但他的家人却拒绝了他。其中部分原因在于，尽管他在观众面前显露了神迹，
he hasn't done so to other people in Thebes. He's kind of in disguise. And already, the punishment that he's visiting on his family for refusing to acknowledge him is kicking in. So we're told that Dionysus' answer, that's Agave, I know. Ortonoway have been driven mad. They've gone out onto the uplands. They put on their kind of, you know, their dainty fawn outfits, and they are roaming the mountains. Pentheus is, he's an absolute square.
但他对底比斯其他人并没有这样做。他某种程度上是在伪装。而且，他因家人拒绝承认他而对其降下的惩罚已经开始生效了。所以我们得知，狄奥尼索斯的母亲，那是阿加韦，我知道。奥托诺埃都被逼疯了。她们走到了高地上。她们穿上那种，你知道的，她们精致的小鹿皮服装，在山里游荡。彭透斯，他是一个绝对古板的人。
He's not into this. He doesn't find it groovy at all. And he is shocked in all kinds of ways. So women running free, that's bad. His grandfather, Cadmus, and Terracius, you remember our old friend, Terracius? Yeah. I had a little stint of as a woman. Yes, and then become a man. But now he's got back into dressing up as a woman
他对此一点也不感兴趣。他觉得这一点也不时髦。他在各种方面都感到震惊。所以女人们四处游荡，这很糟。他的外祖父卡德摩斯，还有特瑞西阿斯，还记得我们的老朋友特瑞西阿斯吗？对。我曾有过一小段当女人的经历。是的，然后变成了男人。但现在他又开始打扮成女人了，
because he and Cadmus have both dressed up as my nads. They're very elderly. You know, they look ridiculous. So again, Pentia is not approving of that. And the claims of Dionysus followers that he's a god, Penthes also thinks this is utterly blasphemous and shocking. And so he orders that Dionysus should be captured, brought into his presence, and then stoned into death.
因为他和卡德摩斯都打扮成了迈纳德女祭司。他们年纪都很大了。你知道，他们看起来荒谬极了。所以同样地，彭透斯并不赞同这一点。而狄奥尼索斯的追随者宣称他是神，彭透斯也认为这绝对是大不敬和令人震惊的。因此他下令抓捕狄奥尼索斯，把他带到自己面前，然后用石头砸死他。
And he also orders that a squad of a crack squad of elite pig men should go up into the mountains and capture the mainads and stop them getting up to their shenanigans. However, obviously, it doesn't work out. Dionysus is captured, but it doesn't take him long to reveal to Pentheus, to the Thebans, to the audience, his terrifying divine power. So Pentheus thinks that Dionysus is being tied up, but in fact, it's a bull that's being tied up. Pentheus can no longer distinguish between this bull in the stable and Dionysus. Dionysus then makes Pentheus's palace shake, collapse, and then the rubble of the palace is consumed by a great blaze of fire. And Pentheus emerges back onto the stage, completely bewildered by this, stabbing at the air. You know, he's starting to lose it. At this point, a herdsman arrives. He's come down from the heights of Mount Ketheron,
他还下令派遣一支精锐的弓箭手精锐小队上山去抓捕迈纳德女祭司，阻止她们胡闹。然而，显而易见，事情并没有成功。狄奥尼索斯被捕了，但他没花多少时间就向彭透斯、向底比斯人、向观众展现了他那可怕的神圣力量。所以彭透斯以为狄奥尼索斯被绑起来了，但事实上被绑起来的是一头公牛。彭透斯再也分不清马厩里的这头公牛和狄奥尼索斯了。接着，狄奥尼索斯使彭透斯的宫殿摇晃、坍塌，然后宫殿的废墟被一场滔天大火吞没。彭透斯重新出现在舞台上，对此感到完全迷惑不解，对着空气乱刺。你知道的，他开始崩溃了。就在这时，一个牧羊人赶到了。他从基思戎山的高处下来，
and he reports what he's seen there. And basically, he's seen the mine ads, and they are picking up snakes, twining them into their hair. They are putting Penthes' elite squad of crack pick men to flight, and the women are doing this armed only with staves tipped with pine cones. So, again, kind of very, very unsettling. And they are going around,
并汇报了他在那里看到的景象。基本上，他看到了迈纳德女祭司，她们抓起蛇，缠在头发上。她们打败了彭透斯那支精锐的突击小队，而且女人们仅仅拿着顶端有松果的手杖就做到了这一点。所以，同样地，这非常非常令人不安。她们四处游荡，
and every time they find a cow or, of bull, they tear it to pieces. And so the herdsman reports, you'd see some ribs or a cleft hoof tossed high and low and rags of flesh hung from pine branches, dripping blood. Now, by this point, it's as though, you know, the ease and whiz are kicking in for Pentheus. He's getting increasingly spaced out. And he essentially is putty now in Dionysus's hands. He does whatever Dionysus tells him to do. And Dionysus persuades Pentheus that what he should really do is go up into the heights and spy on the Maynads and that the best thing, the best way to do that would be for Pentheus to dress up as a woman, to dress up as a minad.
每当她们找到一头母牛或公牛，就会把它撕成碎片。于是牧羊人报告说，你会看到肋骨或分叉的蹄子被抛向空中，碎肉挂在松树枝上，滴着血。现在，到了这个时候，就好像，你知道的，迷幻药效开始在彭透斯身上发作了。他越来越神志不清了。他基本上成了狄奥尼索斯手中的橡皮泥。狄奥尼索斯让他做什么他就做什么。狄奥尼索斯说服彭透斯，他真正应该做的是去高地上监视迈纳德女祭司，而最好的做法、最好的方法就是让彭透斯打扮成一个女人，打扮成一个迈纳德女祭司。
I feel like nothing good is going to, well, I know that nothing good is going to happen to Pentheus. He's making it some bad choices. He is making some, but, you know, then again, he's kind of off his face. And so Pentheus says, yeah, that's a brilliant idea. And by now he's really tripping. So he says, I seem to see two sons, a double Thebes. He looks at Dionysus, and he sees a pair of horns sprouting from his head, and he is starting to recognize the God for what he is. So he puts on his fawn skin dress, and then Dionysus leads him off stage,
我觉得不会有什么好事发生，好吧，我明明知道彭透斯不会有什么好下场。他做出了一些糟糕的选择。他确实做了一些，但话说回来，他当时已经神智不清了。所以彭透斯说，太棒了，这主意绝了。到了现在，他真的嗨大了。所以他说，我好像看到了两个太阳，双重的底比斯。他看着狄奥尼索斯，看到他头上长出了一对角，他开始认出这位神的真面目。于是他穿上鹿皮长裙，然后狄奥尼索斯领着他离开舞台，
and they're going up to the mountain. And it doesn't take long for a messenger to appear on the stage and to report what happened next. And we're told that Pentheus had reached the heights of Mount Kitheron, and he wants a good view of the mainads who are, you know, rampaging around, having their rave, all of that. And so Dionysus pulls down a pine tree and he puts Pentheus on the top of the pine tree and then he twang, you know, he lets the pine snap back up.
他们正朝着山上去。没过多久，一个信使就出现在舞台上，汇报了接下来发生的事情。我们得知彭透斯已经到达了基思戎山的高地，他想好好看看那些狂欢、聚会、四处狂乱的迈纳德女祭司。于是狄奥尼索斯拉下一棵松树，把彭透斯放在松树顶上，然后啪的一声，你知道的，他让松树弹了回去。
So that Pentheus is then at the top of the tree looking down at the Maynads. And then Dionysus, the rotter, yells over to the mainads and says, hey, look at this. There's a spy pointing up at the hapless Pentheus who's on the top of the the tree. And the main house go absolutely mad and they start shaking the tree. And then the herdsman says, from his high perch plunging, crashing to the earth, Pentheus fell with one incessant scream as he understood what end was near. And that passage that you read at the beginning of this show, that is what happens. He is torn to pieces. And shortly afterwards, on stage, Agave appears and she's cradling her son's head. And effectively, you know, what the actor must have been holding is the mask of
这样彭透斯就坐在树顶上俯视着迈纳德女祭司。然后狄奥尼索斯这个混蛋向迈纳德女祭司大喊道：“嘿，快看这个。有个间谍！”指着树顶上倒霉的彭透斯。迈纳德女祭司彻底疯了，她们开始摇晃树木。接着牧羊人说，彭透斯从高高的栖木上坠落，重重地摔向地面，伴随着一声凄厉的尖叫，因为他明白了末日已近。而你在节目开头读的那段文字，就是接下来发生的事。他被撕成了碎片。不久之后，舞台上出现了阿加韦，她怀里抱着儿子的头颅。实际上，你知道的，演员手里拿的一定是
of Pentheus. And presumably Agave is played by the same actor who'd been playing Pentheus. So Agave thinks that what she's holding is the head of a lion. She thinks that's what she's torn to pieces. And it's only gradually in obedience to the promptings of Cadmus, her father, that she kind of comes out of her ecstatic state and realizes what it is she's holding and what it is that she's done. She's devastated. She and her sisters are sent into exile. And Cadmus and his wife are turned into snakes. So, bad day for the royal family of Thebes, and the moral of the story is summed up by Casmus at the very end of the play. If any man derides the unseen world, let him ponder the
彭透斯的面具。而且据推测，扮演阿加韦的演员和刚才扮演彭透斯的应该是同一个人。所以阿加韦以为她手里拿的是狮子的头。她以为那是她撕成碎片的猎物。直到在父亲卡德摩斯的提示下，她才渐渐从狂喜的状态中清醒过来，意识到自己手里拿的是什么，自己做了什么。她崩溃了。她和她的姐妹们被流放了。而卡德摩斯和他的妻子则变成了蛇。所以，对于底比斯王室来说真是糟糕的一天，而这个故事的寓意在戏剧的最后由卡德摩斯做了总结：任何嘲笑无形世界的人，都应当思考彭透斯的
death of Pentheus and believe in the gods. So a blood-soaked d'enumal, an absolutely devastating play. And the obvious question is, what does it mean? What's the point? Because is the, you know, are we to see Pentheus as the villain, as it were, who's being punished? for not embracing the spirit of Dionysus? Or are we, you know, is Pentheus a martyr, a victim? And should we feel sorry for him? And is Dionysus actually a terrible person or terrible God? Yeah.
死亡，并信仰神明。这是一场血流成河的悲剧结局，一部极其震撼的戏剧。显而易见的问题是，这究竟意味着什么？重点是什么？因为，难道我们应该把彭透斯视为恶人，也就是那个因为不接受狄奥尼索斯精神而被惩罚的人吗？还是说，彭透斯是一个殉道者、一个受害者？我们应该为他感到难过吗？狄奥尼索斯其实是一个可怕的人或可怕的神吗？是的。
And I guess that's the point about the green myths, isn't it? That it's impossible to fix a simplistic meaning on something that seems so slippery and so nuanced, but also, frankly, so strange and so terrifying. Absolutely. There are critics who see Pentheus as the villains, see him as, or Dionysus is the villain. You can stage it, I mean, you could stage it as being about the coming of the Nazis. You could cast Dionysus as, you know, as Hitler. Or you could
我想这就是希腊神话的意义所在吧？你不可能给一个看起来如此捉摸不定、细腻微妙，但也坦白讲如此诡异和可怕的事物强加一个单一简化的意义。绝对如此。有些评论家把彭透斯视作恶人，把狄奥尼索斯视作恶人。你可以这样演绎它，我的意思是，你可以把它演绎成关于纳粹的降临。你可以把狄奥尼索斯塑造成希特勒。或者你也可以
stage it with, you know, Pentheus as some boring square who is refusing to drop out and join the hippies. Yeah. And as you say, that is a kind of the measure of the richness of this, of Greek myth and of tragedy, is that two and a half thousand years on, it's still has this kind of richness. It can be interpreted and adapted. But I'm guessing that that's a very modern way of viewing it, right? The Athenians, when they saw it as part of a communal experience, that is a central part of their city's calendar, and you know how important their civic culture is to them. They would not have said, oh, this has multiple meanings, and it's very slippery and nuanced. They would have said, it has one meaning, and the meaning is this. So what is
把它演绎成，彭透斯是一个无聊的古板之人，拒绝放弃现实并加入嬉皮士。是的。正如你所说，这就是希腊神话和悲剧丰富性的衡量标准，两千五百五十年过去了，它依然具有这种丰富性。它可以被诠释和改编。但我猜这是一种非常现代的视角，对吧？雅典人在将它视为集体体验的一部分时，这是他们城市日历的核心部分，而且你知道他们的公民文化对他们有多重要。他们不会说：“哦，这有多重含义，而且非常捉摸不定、细腻微妙。”他们会说：“它只有一个含义，这个含义就是这样的。”那么它究竟是
it? Well, I think the context is key. The fact that they are staring down the barrel of total ruin and they're sitting there watching the dramatic portrayal of a city being utterly destroyed. So Euripides is very precise about this in the back eye, that the ruin that's visited on Pentheus is also a ruin that is visited on Thieves. So to quote Euripides, the city, streets tremble and guilt, as every Theban repents too late, his blindness and his blasphemy. And I think it's impossible to believe that Athenians wouldn't have felt those lies. as incredibly chilling
什么呢？嗯，我认为背景是关键。他们正面临着彻底毁灭的绝境，却坐在那里观看对一个被彻底毁灭的城市的戏剧化描绘。所以欧里庇得斯在《巴克科斯女祭司》中对此非常明确，降临在彭透斯身上的毁灭，同样也是降临在底比斯身上的毁灭。用欧里庇得斯的话来说，城市的街道颤抖着充满罪恶，因为每一个底比斯人都为时已晚地忏悔着他的盲目与大不敬。我想雅典人不可能感受不到那些台词，
and thought about how the ruin that's going to be visited on thieves might well be the ruin that's visited on them. Right. Yeah. And what's more, it's the men who are sitting there thinking about it and they're watching Pentheus, the king, who has responsibility for the day-to-day affairs of his city. In a democracy, it's the mass of the male citizens
觉得它们极其不寒而栗，并且会思考降临在底比斯身上的毁灭是否很可能就是将要降临在他们身上的毁灭。对。是的。不仅如此，坐在那里思考这一切的是男人们，他们正在观看彭透斯这位对城市的日常事务负有责任的国王。在民主制中，是广大男性公民
who have that responsibility. So they're watching Pentheus lead thieves to disaster and they must have been reflecting, well, you know, Pentheus is us. We, we, the citizen body, who have responsibility for the day-to-day running of this city, whether it goes to war, how we conduct that war, we likewise have led our city to ruin. I mean, I think it must have been devastating. But their mistakes, if they are mistakes, have been political, military, diplomatic ones. Pentheus' mistake is that he doesn't fully embrace what you would call Tom to do a Tom Hollandism, the dimension of the supernatural.
承担着这种责任。所以他们看着彭透斯把底比斯引向灾难，他们一定在反思，“好吧，你知道的，彭透斯就是我们。我们，这个负有城市日常运转责任的公民群体，无论是决定开战，还是如何进行这场战争，我们同样把我们的城市引向了毁灭。”我的意思是，这一定让人倍感打击。但他们的错误，如果这算是错误的话，是政治、军事、外交上的错误。彭透斯错在没有完全接受——用汤姆的话来说，来一个“汤姆·霍尔顿主义”——超自然维度的存在。
Is Euripides arguing that that is also the Athenians mistake? Is he a sort of, is there a slightly Savonarola aspects, Savonarola and Florence aspects of this? Basically, you haven't, this is an opportunity for you to revive your gravely voice, Tom, Severnorola's voice. is he but is European is saying the mistakes you know the political mistakes are merely a symptom of a deeper kind of moral spiritual malaise
欧里庇得斯是在争辩说这也是雅典人的错误吗？他是否有一种，这是否带有某种萨沃纳罗拉式的色彩，萨沃纳罗拉与佛罗伦萨的色彩？基本上，你没有……这是一个让你重现你那沙哑嗓音的机会，汤姆，萨沃纳罗拉的嗓音。欧里庇得斯是不是在说，你们犯下的那些错误，你知道的，政治错误，仅仅是更深层次的道德和精神迷失的一种症状？
well as in the back eye so in the dying days of the great war with Sparta the Athenians would take for granted that the gods are actors in the drama of what is happening and normally for the Athenians the readiness of the gods
正如在《巴克科斯女祭司》中一样，在与斯巴达大战的最后日子里，雅典人理所当然地认为神明是正在发生的事情之戏剧中的演员，而且通常对于雅典人来说，神明介入
to intervene in the affairs of their city is seen as a positive. So to quote Greg Anderson, who I've already cited in this series in his book, The Realness of Things Past, for the Athenians, the gods of Attica were not some group of faceless superhuman hired contractors. They were something closer to benevolent governors or caring parents, beings who perpetually monitored and managed the shared local environment, taking a personal interest in the life and well-being of their chosen people. And the chosen people is the demos. That is what the democracy is. It's the rule of the chosen people of Attica, the chosen people of Athena. And this notion of the Athenians as a chosen people of Athena and of other gods as well, worshipped by the Athenians, this embraces
他们城市事务的意愿被视为一件积极的事。正如我在这系列中已经引用过的格雷格·安德森在他的书《往事真实性》（The Realness of Things Past）中所说，对于雅典人来说，阿提卡的神明并不是什么面目模糊的超人雇佣承包商。他们更像是慈爱的总督或关怀备至的父母，这些存在时刻监视并管理着共同的本地环境，对他们所选民的生活和福祉抱有个人的兴趣。而所选民就是“德莫斯”（demos，人民）。这就是民主制的本质。它是阿提卡所选民、雅典娜所选民的统治。而这种将雅典人视为雅典娜以及雅典人所崇拜的其他神明之选民的概念，不仅涵盖了
women as well as men. And in fact, it is women far more than men who are entrusted with the rituals that exist to please the gods and thereby to keep the demos secure. So that's why these women are going off to the temple of Dionysus in the swamp. They're the ones who preside over the sacred rituals, but there are other rituals as well. So from childhood they've been doing it. So at the age of 10, we're told the girls of Athens go out to a shrine of Artemis, the goddess of the hunt on the shores of Attica,
男性，也涵盖了女性。事实上，比起男性，女性更多地被托付以取悦神明从而保证“德莫斯”安全的各种仪式。这就是为什么这些女人们要前往沼泽地的狄奥尼索斯神庙。她们是主持神圣仪式的人，不过也有其他的仪式。所以从小她们就在做这件事。我们得知，雅典的女孩在10岁时，会前往阿提卡海岸狩猎女神阿尔忒弥斯的神社，
and there they turn into bears and they run with Artemis. Or they tend the sacred snake on the Acropolis, or they weave robes for Athena, which are carried up onto the Acropolis. are used to adorn her statues. And Euripides himself is, you know, he is fully conscious of this role that women are mandated to play in securing the health of the Demos and of Athens, because we have a fragment from an otherwise lost play in which he states this explicitly. So to quote this fragment, as regards relations with the gods, matters which I judge to be more important than
并在那里变成熊，与阿尔忒弥斯一起奔跑。或者她们照看卫城上的神圣灵蛇，或者她们为雅典娜织造长袍，这些长袍被带到卫城上，用来装饰她的雕像。欧里庇得斯本人，你知道的，他完全意识到女性在确保“德莫斯”和雅典健康方面被委以的这种角色，因为我们从一部已经失传的戏剧中找到了一个残篇，他在其中明确地阐述了这一点。所以引用这个残篇的话：关于与神明的关系，我认为这比任何事情都重要的事情，
anything. It is we women who have the leading role to play. So he's ventriloquizing a woman in this fragment for there are many rights which cannot legitimately be performed by men but which flourish when women conduct them the order which prevails in the engagements of mortals with the gods is then it can be said a female one and so that being so again imagine how terrifying it must have been to sit there knowing that your city is on the brink of total ruin watching women running amok worshipping Dionysus in a way that causes ruin for the state. In the Bacchai, women are embroiled in the collapse of Thebes just as much as men are. And again, I think that the relevance of this for the first audience of the Bacchai would have been stupefying.
我们女性才是扮演主要角色的那一方。所以他在这个残篇中借女性之口表达心声：因为有许多仪式是男性无法合法执行的，但当由女性主持时却能蓬勃发展。凡人与神明交往中的秩序，可以说是一种女性的秩序。既然如此，再次想象一下，当坐在那里明知自己的城市正处于彻底毁灭的边缘，却看着女人们四处狂乱、以一种导致国家毁灭的方式崇拜狄奥尼索斯时，那是多么令人恐惧。在《巴克科斯女祭司》中，女性和男性一样被卷入了底比斯的崩溃之中。同样，我认为这对《巴克科斯女祭司》的首批观众来说具有震撼人心的相关性。
They must have thought that, I mean, what's the lesson of the Bacchai? That men can adopt policies that are disastrous, but also that women who are mandated to keep the gods on side can run completely amok and be complicit in the destruction of the city as well. So I think that that is a theme that must have been overwhelming for the audience, the sense that men and women alike are embroiled in the disaster that the Athenians like the Thebans are facing. And what is the argument that Euripides is making then? What is the argument that he's, you know, how does this story illustrate the deeper failings, you know, is it that they've, that they haven't honoured the gods,
他们一定觉得，我的意思是，《巴克科斯女祭司》的教训是什么？男人会采取灾难性的政策，但那些被委以使神明站在他们一边的女性也可能彻底疯狂，并同样成为毁灭城市的帮凶。所以我想，这是一个会让观众感到难以承受的主题，那种男女都不可避免地被卷入灾难之中的感知，正如雅典人和底比斯人所面临的那样。那么欧里庇得斯提出的论点究竟是什么呢？他的论点是，你知道的，这个故事是如何说明更深层次的失败的，是因为他们没有尊崇神明，
that they've lived in an ungodly way, that they have... Yes, I think that's absolutely, I think Euripides is saying that, well, I mean, it's a drama. He's not saying it, but it's a possibility that is haunting the contours of the drama. He's saying that men, like Pentheus, in the day-to-day running, they can, they can disrespect the gods, they can lead their city into disastrous policies, but also that it's possible for women who are mandated to honor the gods and to keep the gods on side, that they can also fail in that responsibility. And that if men and women both fail, then the consequences for a city is disastrous. Now, that, of course, is to assume that the gods are real. And there is another
因为他们过着不敬神的生活，因为他们……是的，我想绝对是这样，我认为欧里庇得斯是在说，好吧，我的意思是，这是一部戏剧。他并不是在直说，但这是一种萦绕在戏剧轮廓之中的可能性。他在说，像彭透斯这样的男人们，在日常治理中，他们可能会不尊重神明，他们可能会把自己的城市引向灾难性的政策，但也可能出现这种情况：那些被委以尊崇神明并让神明站在他们一边的女性，也可能在那项职责上失败。如果男女双方都失败了，那么对城市而言后果将是灾难性的。当然，这前提是假设神明是真实的。还有另一种
possibility, one that is not countenanced in the back eye, where the God, you know, Dionysus is on the stage. The last messages believe in the gods. But Euripides was. notorious for having explored the possibility that the gods did not exist in other plays. So, again, another fragment that hasn't survived in total from a play called Belerophon. And Belerophon was a hero who fights the chimera. Fights the chimera and rides around on Pegasus, the magical flying horse. And in it, Belerophon describes murderous leaders. So, you know, leaders of cities that come to disaster.
可能性，一种在《巴克科斯女祭司》中未被认可的可能性，在那里神明，你知道的，狄奥尼索斯就在舞台上。最后的警示是信仰神明。但欧里庇得斯以在其其他戏剧中探讨神明不存在的可能性而闻名。所以，同样地，有一部名为《柏勒罗丰》（Belerophon）的戏剧，其中的一个残篇并未完整保存下来。柏勒罗丰是一位与奇美拉战斗的英雄。与奇美拉战斗并骑着魔法飞马珀伽索斯四处飞行。在剧中，柏勒罗丰描述了那些凶残的领袖——
and he says he describes these murderous leaders people who deprive citizens of their property and break their oaths to sack cities and despite this they prosper more than those who live piously in peace every day I know two of small cities that revere the gods which are subject to larger more impious ones overcome as they are by a more numerous army
你知道的，那些导致城市走向灾难的领袖——
so that has a real resonance in the the terrible war between Athens and Spartan all these kind of things have happened and in it Balerophon argues therefore there can be no gods because if there were gods, and they wouldn't permit crimes like this to happen. Exactly. And of course, I suppose you could say Belorferon is just a character.
他描述了这些凶残的领袖，剥夺公民财产、背弃誓言洗劫城市的人，尽管如此，他们却比那些每日在和平中虔诚生活的人过得更好。我每天都知道有两座崇拜神明的小城市，它们却屈服于更大、更不虔诚的城市，被数量更多的军队所击败。
Euripides doesn't believe this himself. But for Euripides to imagine a character who thinks like that suggests that there must be people who think like that. He's not going to imagine the unimaginable. So Euripides is countenancing the possibility at least that there is an argument to be had about whether the gods are real. Yeah, well, we don't know what Euripides himself thought. And it's worth, I mean,
所以这在雅典与斯巴达之间那场可怕的战争中产生了真正的共鸣，所有这些类似的事情都发生了。而在其中，柏勒罗丰辩称，因此不可能有神明，因为如果有神明，他们绝不允许这样的罪行发生。确实如此。当然，我想你可以说柏勒罗丰只是一个角色。
emphasizing that Belerophon does have a magical flying horse. And in the play, he uses, he flies on Pegasus up to Mount Olympus to see whether the gods are real or not and is, they are. They are because he gets, yes. So in the play, his doubt is answered in a kind of tragic way. But it is a staple of the comedies which are being staged in the Dionysa as well as the tragedies. Euripides appears in comedies by Aristophanes, the most famous of all.
欧里庇得斯本人并不一定这样认为。但对于欧里庇得斯来说，能够想象出一个这样思考的角色，表明必定有这样思考的人存在。他不会去想象不可想象的事。所以欧里庇得斯至少承认了这种可能性，即关于神明是否真实存在是有一场争论可以进行的。是的，嗯，我们不知道欧里庇得斯自己是怎么想的。值得强调的是，
all the great Athenian comic writers. And for Aristophanes, it's a kind of standing joke that Euripides is an atheist, to quote Aristophanes, he's always persuading men that there aren't any gods. And for Aristophanes, Euripides is the spokesman for a kind of a real, a sinister, elitist trend. Metropolitan atheists. Metropolitan liberal trend. Right.
柏勒罗丰确实有一匹神奇的飞马。在剧中，他骑着珀伽索斯飞上奥林匹斯山去看看神明是否真实存在，结果发现他们确实存在。他们确实存在，因为他遭到了，是的。所以在剧中，他的怀疑以一种悲剧的方式得到了解答。但这也是喜剧的常见题材，这些喜剧和悲剧一样也在狄奥尼索斯节上上演。欧里庇得斯出现在阿里斯托芬的喜剧中，阿里斯托芬是最著名的所有伟大雅典喜剧作家之一。对于阿里斯托芬来说，一个长期的笑话就是欧里庇得斯是个无神论者，用阿里斯托芬的话来说，他总是说服人们根本没有神明。对阿里斯托芬来说，欧里庇得斯是一种真实、阴暗、精英主义倾向的代言人。大都市的无神论者。大都市的自由派倾向。对。
And this trend essentially is to believe that the stories that are told by Homer and by Hesiod and by the other ancient poets are inadequate to explain and characterise the true character of the divine. And this is a trend that is more than a century old by the time that Euripides is writing the Bacchi. And it originates on the opposite side of the Aegean. to Athens, so in what's now Turkey, Anatolia, in the mid-6th century BC. And in time, so just a few decades after the death of Euripides, this kind of intellectual trend will come to be called Philosophia, the love of wisdom. So philosophy, which is probably the most, well, I mean, not probably, I mean, it is the most radical and influential of all the intellectual achievements of ancient Greece. And it originates as a reaction against the stories that were told by the poets, very
而这种倾向本质上是认为由荷马、赫西奥德和其他古代诗人所讲述的故事不足以解释和刻画神明的真实特征。当欧里庇得斯写下《巴克科斯女祭司》时，这种倾向已经存在了一个多世纪。它起源于爱琴海的对岸，即现在的土耳其、安纳托利亚，也就是公元前6世纪中叶。假以时日，就在欧里庇得斯死后短短几十年，这种知识倾向将被称作“哲学家”（Philosophia），即对智慧的热爱。也就是哲学，这可能是——嗯，不是可能，我的意思是，它是古希腊所有智力成就中最激进、最具影响力的一项。它起源于对诗人们所讲述的故事的反抗，非常
specifically. And so it's kind of manifests itself in all kinds of ways. So it's critique of the kind of homeric anthropomorphic gods, the gods who look like humans. It's completely devastating. So there's a guy called Xenophonies who writes, if cattle and horses and lions had hands or could paint with their hands and create work such as men do. Horses like horses and cattle like cattle also would depict the gods shapes and make their bodies of such a sort as the form they themselves have. In other words, we only think that their gods look human because we're human. If we were horses, we'd think they look like horses. As it often, he goes on to say that black people worship black gods and that redhead people worship redhead gods. The redhead gods, I'm not
具体地说就是这样。所以它以各种方式表现出来。因此它对荷马式的拟人化神明——那些长得像人类的神明的批判是彻底摧毁性的。有个叫色诺芬尼的人写道：“如果牛、马或狮子有手，或者能用手画画，并能像人一样进行创作，那么马就会把神明的形象画成马的样子，牛就会画成牛的样子，把它们的身体塑造得和他们自己拥有的形态一样。”换句话说，我们之所以认为神明长得像人，只是因为我们是人。如果我们是马，我们就会觉得他们长得像马。色诺芬尼接着说，黑人崇拜黑皮肤的神明，红发的人崇拜红发的
aware of any redhead gods. The Thracians, Dominic, apparently the Thracians had red hair and they worship redhead gods. Okay, well, there you go. I stand corrected. Other philosophers insist that Zeus doesn't hurl thunderbolts, that the sun isn't a fiery chariot, that the universe instead is formed out of air or moisture or fire out of kind of universal eternal substances. And the very word mythos, which in Homer, signifies a story that is infused with authority,
红发神明。我不知道有什么红发神明。色雷斯人，多米尼克，据说色雷斯人有红头发，他们崇拜红发神明。好吧，原来如此。我收回前言。其他哲学家坚持认为宙斯不会投掷雷电，太阳不是炽热的战车，宇宙反而是由空气、湿气或火——由某种宇宙永恒物质构成的。而“神话”（Mythos）这个词，在荷马那里意指一个充满权威性、
with truth that actually it means the opposite that a mythos a myth is a fable a fantasy and the philosophers oppose this
充满真实性的故事，实际上它的含义却反了过来，即一个“神话”（myth）是一则寓言、一种幻想，而哲学家们将其与
to another word logos which means recent argument so you have you have myth fantasy and you have
另一个词“逻各斯”（Logos）对立起来，后者意指理性论证。所以你有神话幻想，也有
logos recent argument so in a sense this answers the question I asked in the very first episode of the series which is
逻各斯理性论证。从某种意义上说，这回答了我在本系列第一集中提出的问题，即
did the Greeks genuinely believe this did they believe there were people with heads with the head of a ball or people on flying horses and all this kind of stuff. And the answer is clearly, no, a lot of the, a lot of Greeks or some Greeks, not a lot,
希腊人真的相信这些吗？他们相信有人长着公牛的头，或者有人骑着飞马以及诸如此类的事情吗？答案显然是，不，许多希腊人，或者说某些希腊人——不是许多，
maybe a, will come to how many, did not and said, come on, this is rubbish. This is a, it's interesting, they are, the philosophy is born in opposition to story, right? That's basically your, what you're suggesting. It absolutely is. And the most famous philosopher of all, who was, you know, a young man in his 20, when the back i was staged and then when when athens fell the following year he goes so far as to argue that in an ideal state the poets homer hesiod and so on should be banned and that man of course is plato and plato in in the republic his attempt to um describe the the ideal form that a city
也许是一部分，我们稍后会讨论有多少人——并不相信，并说：“得了吧，这都是胡扯。”这很有趣，哲学是在对故事的反抗中诞生的，对吧？这基本上就是你所暗示的。完全是这样。而最著名的哲学家，当《巴克科斯女祭司》上演时他还是一名20多岁的年轻人，然后在次年雅典沦陷时，他甚至走得更远，认为在一个理想国度中，诗人荷马、赫西奥德等人应该被禁止，这个人当然就是柏拉图。而柏拉图在《理想国》中试图描述城市应采取的理想形态时，写道：诗歌滋养并浇灌激情，而不是将其扑灭；她让激情统治，尽管如果人类想要变得更加幸福美好，本应对其加以控制。
should take wrote poetry feeds and waters the passions instead of drying them up she lets them rule although they ought to be controlled if mankind is ever to become happier and better. And so, therefore, he says, you know, Hesia shouldn't be allowed in all this stuff about Kronos cutting off the testicles. I mean, it's just unacceptable. Controvenes all kinds of health and safety regulations. Well, I don't think that's the prime objective. But, I mean, essentially what he says is that this is an invitation to insurrection.
所以，因此他说，你知道的，不应该允许赫西奥德讲述克洛诺斯割掉睾丸的所有这些事情。我的意思是，这简直不可接受。违反了各种健康和安全条例。好吧，我不认为那是首要目标。但是，我的意思是，他本质上所说的是，这是对叛乱的煽动。
Yeah. You know, I mean, before you know it, all kinds of people will be having their testicles cut off, and we can't have that. And he also thinks that a hero seducing Zeus and, you know, all this, that it's just blasphemous. And he doesn't want any of it. So he still very much believes, I mean, if he thinks is blasphemous, he believes there is a supernatural element that needs to be treated with respect. But he thinks these are basically silly children's stories that introduce the gods and actually demean them. Yes.
你知道的，我的意思是，不知不觉中，各种各样的人都会去把他们的睾丸割掉，我们可不能容许这种事发生。他还认为一个英雄诱惑宙斯以及诸如此类的事简直就是大不敬。他对此完全不赞成。所以他仍然非常坚信——我的意思是，如果他认为这是大不敬，说明他相信存在一个需要予以尊重的超自然要素——但他认为这些基本上是引入神明却实际贬低了神明的愚蠢儿童故事。是的。
And so, therefore, Homer should be banned. Right. And so, you know, you said lots of people believe this. So the question then is, does this mean the end for the end for the? the myths. With the emergence of philosophy, with Plato and so on, is myth going to die? And it doesn't and for two reasons. And the first of these is that the stories that are told of the gods of the heroes and so on are so intimately interwoven into the fabric of Greek life, you know, all the cults, the festivals and so on, but also just the mental headspace. I mean, these stories are
所以，因此，荷马应该被禁。对。所以，你知道的，你说了很多人相信这一点。那么问题来了，这是否意味着神话的终结？随着哲学的兴起，随着柏拉图等人的出现，神话会消亡吗？并没有，原因有两个。其中第一个是，关于神明、英雄等的故事与希腊生活的方时刻刻如此紧密地交织在一起，你知道的，所有的宗教仪式、节日等等，甚至还有精神空间。我的意思是，这些故事
so powerful, they're so strong. They can't just be banished. And the Sandbrook perspective on this surely would be. Most people don't think about this at all. They're doing tilling their fields. Exactly. Exactly. They're not intellectuals. They're not worrying about philosophy or whatever. So myth remains part of, you know, it's just the kind of the air that they're breathing in. Exactly. That would make total sense. They don't actually, if you said to somebody, are you interested in the stories of Eucing Kronos or whatever? They'd say, sure, everyone knows these stories. Do you believe them? They'd say, I don't really think about them that much, to be honest with you.
太强大了，太有力了。它们不可能被简单地驱逐。而桑德布鲁克对此的视角肯定会是：大多数人根本不考虑这些。他们正在田里耕作。完全正确。完全正确。他们不是知识分子。他们不担心哲学或诸如此类的事情。所以神话依然是，你知道的，就像他们呼吸的空气一样。完全说得通。如果有人对你说，“你对克洛诺斯诱惑等人的故事感兴趣吗？”他们会说，“当然，每个人都知道这些故事。”“你相信它们吗？”他们会说，“老实说，我其实没怎么想过这件事。”
I mean, we observe the rituals, of course, but I've got better things to think about. So if we look at Plato, he sets up this school outside Athens called the Academy. And it's so influential that in the long run, you know, it gives us the word academic. But it's worth emphasizing it stands outside Athens. It's not in the city. And it is named after the tomb of a hero, Academus. So the presence of myth is there right. in the heart of Plato's school.
“我的意思是，我们当然遵守仪式，但我有更重要的事情要想。”所以如果我们看看柏拉图，他在雅典城外建立了一所名为“学园”（Academy）的学校。它影响深远，以至于从长远来看，它给我们留下了“学术的”（academic）这个词。但值得强调的是，它矗立在雅典城外。它不在城内。它是以英雄阿卡德莫斯（Academus）的墓地命名的。所以神话的存在就盘踞在
And it, you know, the Academy cannot remotely compare for kind of splendor and cost and prestige with the temples that continue to stand in Athens. No one is going to say, the Academy is more important than the Parthenon. Right. So it's the equivalent of a, I don't know, a liberal arts college in upstate New York where they're coming up with all kinds of wacky theories and whatnot on, and they're living outside capitalism. But actually in New York City, no one cares and they're just, you know, kind of
柏拉图学校的核心。而且，你知道的，在宏伟、成本和声望方面，学园完全无法与雅典至今耸立的神庙相提并论。没有人会说学园比帕台农神庙更重要。所以这就相当于，我不知道，纽约州北部的某所文理学院，他们在那里想出各种古怪的理论之类的东西，过着脱离资本主义的生活。但实际上在纽约市，根本没有人关心这个，他们只是，你知道的，那种……
of. Yes. I suppose kind of. But the other thing to emphasize is that philosophy doesn't banish myth. It just creates a new one. So Xenophonies, even as he's saying, you know, cows would worship cows. What he's really disputing is the fact that the gods look like humans. He absolutely believes in a god. Yeah. I mean, and it sounds very much, you know, it will sound familiar to monotheists today. Zonophonis, right, there is one god, greatest among gods and men, similar to mortals, neither in shape nor in thought. And those who are arguing that, you know, the cosmos is made of air or fire or moisture or whatever,
是的，差不多吧。但另一件需要强调的事情是，哲学并没有驱逐神话。它只是创造了一个新神话。所以色诺芬尼，即便在他宣称“牛会崇拜牛”的时候，他真正反驳的其实是神明长得像人这一事实。他绝对相信有一位神。是的。我的意思是，这听起来非常——这对今天的唯一神论者来说会觉得很熟悉。色诺芬尼说，只有一个神，在神明和人类中是最伟大的，无论在形态还是思想上都不与凡人相似。而那些争论宇宙是由空气、湿气或火等构成的学者们，
the assumption is that these elements are themselves divine. So in that sense, the whole cosmos is divine. And Plato is himself the greatest of all myth makers. And what he does with momentous consequences for the way that we continue to think today is that he makes the real unreal and the unreal, real, because what he's arguing is that beyond the world as we perceive it, there is another world which is perfect, immortal, unchangeable. And the way that this is always summed up is that
他们的假设是这些元素本身就是神圣的。从这个意义上讲，整个宇宙都是神圣的。而柏拉图本人就是最伟大的神话创造者。他对我们今天继续思考的方式产生了重大影响，那就是他将真实变得虚幻，将虚幻变得真实。因为他所争论的是，在我们所感知的世界之外，还有一个完美、不朽、不变的世界。对此通常的总结方式是，
there are, you know, you have tables, all kinds of tables, but these are merely reflections of the perfect table that kind of exists as in an ideal state. So what Plato is doing, he's banishing the Homeric gods, but he's enshrining new gods. And these are kind of of essentially abstract nouns, you know, kind of the just, the beautiful, the good, whatever. And rather than a Bacaea, so going out and celebrating on the mountain, what Plato is offering his followers is an assent, the idea that the individual has an ideal form, namely, you know, in the form of a soul or whatever you want to call it, and that the soul can ascend from the dimension of the material to, as Plato puts it, the best of everything which can be
有各种各样的桌子，各种各样的桌子，但这些仅仅是以理想状态存在的完美桌子的倒影。所以柏拉图所做的，是驱逐了荷马的神明，但却奉上了新神。这些基本上是抽象名词，你知道的，正义、美丽、善良等等。与其进行《巴克科斯女祭司》式的狂欢，即走上山去庆祝，不如说柏拉图为他的追随者提供了一种提升，即认为个体拥有理想形态，也就是灵魂的形式或者你想怎么称呼它，灵魂可以从物质维度提升到柏拉图所说的那样：一切可通过思想理解且永恒的事物中最好的一种。而这实际上就是神。这个概念将对基督教产生巨大的影响。对伊斯兰教。对伊斯兰教。正如沃尔特·布尔克特（Walter Burkert）在他关于希腊宗教的伟大著作中所说：自柏拉图以来，没有任何一种神学不站在他的阴影之下。所以从某种意义上说，柏拉图所体现的希腊对神话的反抗，同时也包括亚里士多德和其他哲学家，这是汇入基督教和伊斯兰教崛起之中的那条大河的一部分。
comprehended by thought and which is eternal. And this in effect is God. And this concept is going to be a massive influence on Christianity. On Islam. On Islam. So to quote Walter Burkart in his great book on Greek religion, since Plato, there has been no theology which has not stood in his shadow. So there's a sense in which the Greek reaction against myth that Plato exemplifies, but you also have Aristotle and other philosophers too. This is part of the Great River which will feed into the emergence of Christianity and Islam
可以通过思想理解且永恒的事物。这实际上就是上帝。这个概念将对基督教产生巨大的影响。对伊斯兰教。对伊斯兰教。因此，引用瓦尔特·布克哈特在他关于希腊宗教的伟大著作中的话，自柏拉图以来，没有任何神学不处于他的阴影之下。因此，在某种意义上，柏拉图所体现的希腊对神话的反抗，以及亚里士多德和其他哲学家也是如此。这是将汇入基督教和伊斯兰教诞生的伟大长河的一部分。
and therefore is of titanic significance, I think. So now with Plato and with his ideas we are heading towards we're not quite there yet but we're heading towards the Hellenistic era, the age associate with Alexander the Great and his successes. And I guess the obvious question
因此我认为这具有极其重大的意义。那么现在，随着柏拉图和他的思想，我们正在走向——虽然还没完全走到，但我们正在走向希腊化时代，也就是与亚历山大大帝及其继任者相关的时代。我想显而易见的问题是，
is after Plato and after the, you know, the massive of political disruption of the emergence of Macedon and Alexander and his empire. What does this mean for Greek mythology and the Greek stories of the gods? And how does Alexander in particular, how does he come to it? Because he assumes such massive existential significance. How does he change the way that Greeks think about the relation between mortal and the immortal? And Tom, this takes us to one of my favorite Greek myths,
在柏拉图之后，在经历了马其顿崛起、亚历山大及其帝国的巨大政治动荡之后，这对希腊神话和希腊诸神的故事意味着什么？尤其是亚历山大，他是如何看待这一点的？因为他具有如此巨大的存在主义意义。他是如何改变希腊人对凡人与不朽之间关系的看法的？汤姆，这把我们带到了我最喜欢的希腊神话之一，
which is the story of Jason and the Argonauts, the quest for the golden fleece. And this is what we'll be doing next time, isn't it? And the exciting thing is, so we actually have our own crew. We have our own Argonauts, and they can listen to that episode right away. Is there any way that somebody who's not on the Argo right now could join the Argo? Do you know of any such way? They absolutely could. They could sign up to the Argo by going to The Rest Is History.com and joining the merry crew there
也就是伊阿宋和阿尔戈英雄的故事，即寻找金羊毛的历程。这就是我们下期要讲的内容，对吧？令人兴奋的是，我们其实有自己的船员。我们有自己的阿尔戈英雄，他们可以马上收听那一集。对于现在不在阿尔戈号上的人，有没有什么办法加入阿尔戈号呢？你知道有什么方法吗？他们绝对可以。他们可以通过访问The Rest Is History.com并加入那里的欢乐船员队伍来报名加入阿尔戈号，
and going to win the Golden Fleece. And if you think this last half hour of this show, was absolutely mind-blowing and life-changing. Let me tell you, that episode on Jason and the Argonauts will knock everything that's gone before and the rest is history into a cockt hat. So don't delay. Join the Argo.
去赢得金羊毛。如果你觉得这节目的最后半小时简直让人脑洞大开、颠覆人生，那我告诉你，关于伊阿宋和阿尔戈英雄的那一集，将会把之前所有的内容以及《The Rest is History》的其他节目都比得黯然失色。所以不要犹豫，加入阿尔戈号吧。
Sign up at the rest is history and listen to it right away. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Hey, it's Anthony Scaramucci, and I want to tell you about my podcast Open Book, which just joined the Goalhanger Network, which we're all very proud of. In my latest episode, I interviewed Goalhanger's very own James Holland. We spoke about World War II and what World War II teaches us about today. Here's a clip. Prime Minister Winston Churchill. Well, I think he was a great man. I think he was a man of vision. He was a man of enormous geopolitical. understanding. And he was a man who offered possibilities. When you're in a life and death struggle, you need people that can persuade you. You need people that combined you. You need
在The Rest is History上注册并立即收听。再见。拜拜。嘿，我是安东尼·斯卡拉穆奇，我想向你介绍我的播客《Open Book》，它刚刚加入Goalhanger网络，我们对此都感到非常自豪。在我的最新一集中，我采访了Goalhanger自己的詹姆斯·霍兰德。我们谈论了第二次世界大战以及二战对今天的启示。以下是一个片段。温斯顿·丘吉尔首相。嗯，我认为他是个伟人。我认为他是一个有远见的人。他是一个拥有巨大地缘政治理解力的人。他是一个能够提供可能性的人。当你处于生死存亡的斗争中时，你需要能够说服你的人。你需要能够将你凝聚在一起的人。你需要
men of vision of charisma. That's the problem with the moment since we haven't got those guys. I mean, you know, he's flawed, of course. All the great men are. But thank goodness for the developed world and the democratic world that he was political leader of Great Britain in 1940 and throughout the whole of World War II. He literally, in so many different ways, man of the century, I think because Roosevelt was a charmer. Roosevelt was a great strategist. He pulled the Americans through the Depression and helped him manage the war. But without Churchill holding ground in May and June of 1940, it would have been a much darker, much worse world. It would have been not a lot that the Americans could have done without Churchill's steadfastness and his inspiration to his fellow citizens.
有远见、有个人魅力的人。这就是目前的问题所在，因为我们没有这样的人。我的意思是，你知道的，他当然有缺点。所有的伟人都一样。但对于发达世界和民主世界来说，庆幸的是他在1940年以及整个二战期间担任英国的政治领袖。他字面意思上，在许多不同的方面，都是世纪伟人，我认为因为罗斯福是一个有魅力的人。罗斯福是一位伟大的战略家。他带领美国人度过了大萧条，并帮助他们管理了战争。但如果没有丘吉尔在1940年5月和6月坚守阵地，世界将会变得黑暗得多、糟糕得多。如果没有丘吉尔的坚定不移以及对同胞的鼓舞，美国人将无能为力。
If you want to hear the full episode, just search open book wherever you get your podcast. You are not luminous, Watson, but you are a conductor of light. Here they are. Dr. Mortimer, I presume. Yes, hi. John. Dr. John Watson. Who is your client? He was my client.
如果你想收听完整节目，只需在任何你获取播客的地方搜索《Open Book》。你并不发光，华生，但你是光的传导者。他们来了。莫蒂默博士，我想是的。是的，嗨。约翰。约翰·华生医生。你的委托人是谁？他曾是我的委托人。
Sir Charles Baskerville. Keep reading. A local shepherd noted, I... saw first that of the maid, Hugo Baskerville passed me thence on his black mare, and there behind him, running mute upon his track, such a hound of hell that God forbid should ever be at my heels. I wish I felt better in my mind about it. It's an ugly business once, an ugly, dangerous business. And the more I see of it, the less I like it, I shall be very glad to have you back safe from me. found in Baker Street Passport
查尔斯·巴斯克维尔爵士。继续读。当地的一个牧羊人记录道，我……首先看到的是女仆，雨果·巴斯克维尔骑着他的黑母马从我身旁经过，在他身后，是一只无声追赶的地狱猎犬，愿上帝保佑它永远不要追到我的脚后跟。我对这件事感觉心里很不踏实。这从来都不是什么好事，这是一件丑陋、危险的事。我对它了解越多，就越不喜欢它，能把你安全地接回来我真的很高兴。在贝克街护照中发现
Hello Goldhanger Presents You're not Sherlock Holmes I'm Henry Baskerville From one of the biggest audio dramas of all time Is it bother you? Like in a creepy kind of way? Like in
你好，Goalhanger Presents。你可不是夏洛克·福尔摩斯。我是亨利·巴斯克维尔。来自有史以来最伟大的广播剧之一。这困扰着你吗？就像那种毛骨悚然的方式吗？就像那种
there's an evil giant hound that likes The taste of Baskerville's kind of way The seminal gothic novel by Arthur Conan Doyle They're watching Who? Who are watching? It's not safe. I could just make out its pitch black form.
有一只邪恶的巨型猎犬喜欢巴斯克维尔家族这种口味的方式。亚瑟·柯南·道尔的开创性哥特小说。他们在看着。谁？谁在看？这不安全。我只能辨认出它漆黑的轮廓。
Welcome to deepest. Everything a hellish void. Darkest. For this piercing yellow glow of eyes. Dark mark. What do you want? Of giant facts. No.
欢迎来到最深处。万物皆为地狱般的虚空。最黑暗处。为了这刺眼的黄色目光。黑暗印记。你想要什么？巨大的事实。不。
Sherlock and Cole. The Hound of the Baskervilles. Listen now. Five stars, says the eye paper. Hugely popular, says The Guardian. A successful reinvention of homes for a younger generation, says the times. Search Sherlock and Co. wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
夏洛克与公司。巴斯克维尔的猎犬。立即收听。《i报》评为五星。卫报称其极受欢迎。《泰晤士报》称其为针对年轻一代福尔摩斯的成功重塑。在您获取播客的任何地方搜索《Sherlock & Co.》。这集节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。